GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS DAVID CHIU WAI AND
THE CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
HOUSING COMMITTEE VELTMAN
COMMITTEE I WANT TO WELCOME ALL
OF YOU TO THIS JOINT HEARING OF
ARE SIMPLY HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE.
AS WELL AS THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WE ARE JOINED BY THE
CHAIR OF THAT COMMITTEE --
CENTER HANNAH BETH JACKSON TO MY
LEFT.
PURSUANT TO SP TWELVE FIFTY
THREE CHAPTER SIX NINETY SEVEN
STATUTES OF TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN WHEN A STATEWIDE
INITIATIVE REACHES 25% OF THE
SIGNATURES NEEDED TO QUALIFY A
MEASURE FOR THE BALLOT.
THE INITIATIVE IS REFERRED TO
LEGISLATIVE POLICY COMMITTEES
FOR A HEARING.
THIS IS THE HEARING ARE RELATED
TO INITIATIVE EIGHTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN TO EXPAND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AUTHORITY TO ENACT
RENT CONTROL ON RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTY.
LET ME STATE THAT THIS COMMITTEE
CAN TAKE NO ACTION ON THE
INITIATIVE BUT CAN HEAR
TESTIMONY TO DESCRIBES
INITIATIVE.
AND POSITIONS FOR AND AGAINST.
BEFORE WE GET STARTED I WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO GIVE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THIS HEARING.
WE WILL FIRST HEAR FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WHO
WALK US THROUGH THE INITIATIVE
THEY ARE NOT IN A POSITION TO
GIVE US AN OPINION ON THE
INITIATIVE.
BUT RATHER CAN DESCRIBE
INITIATIVE INCLUDING ITS FISCAL
IMPACTS.
WE WILL THEN HEAR FROM A PANEL
OF WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND A
PANEL IN OPPOSITION TO THE
INITIATIVE.
EACH PANEL HAS A TOTAL OF THIRTY
MINUTES.
AFTER THE FORMAL PRESENTATIONS
WE WILL OPEN UP THE HEARING TO
PUBLIC COMMENT.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC CAN STATE
THEIR NAME THEIR POSITION ON THE
INITIATIVE AND WHERE THEY'RE
FROM IN THE STATE.
WE NEED TO BE STRICT IN THIS
REQUIREMENT SINCE WE HAVE MANY
PEOPLE NOT ONLY IN THIS ROOM BUT
IN OVERFLOW ROOMS WHO WANT TO
TESTIFY ON EITHER SIDE AND WE
WANT TO BE RESPECTFUL.
OF EVERYONE'S TIME I'LL JUST SAY
LOGISTICALLY NOW REPEAT THIS --
WHEN WE GET TO PUBLIC COMMENT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE MICROPHONES
BOTH ON THE LEFT AND THE RIGHT
OF THE MAIN FLOOR OF THIS
HEARING ROOM AS WELL AS IN?
OUR THE BALCONY UP WILL TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT FIRST FROM THE
MAIN FLOOR THEN FROM THE BALCONY
AFTER WE'VE HEARD FROM FOLKS
FROM THE MAIN FLOOR WILL ASK
PEOPLE TO DEPART.
SO WE CAN BRING INDIVIDUALS FROM
THE OVERFLOW --
INTO THIS HEARING ROOM SO THEY
CAN ALSO TESTIFIED WE WILL DO
THE SAME.
UP WITH UP FOLKS IN THE BALCONY
AND WILL ALTERNATE LEFT AND
RIGHT ON THE MAIN FLOOR THEN
LEFT TO RIGHT ON THE BALCONY AND
THEN WILL CONTINUE BACK TO THE
MAIN FLOOR --
WITH THAT --
AND I ALSO WANT TO STATE ONE
OTHER THING DURING THIS --
WHICH IS IN THIS HEARING AS IS
THE CASE IN OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS THERE WILL BE NO
APPLAUSE OR A OR EXPRESSIONS OF
SUPPORT.
UP OR OPPOSITION DURING ANYONE'S
TESTIMONY OUT OF RESPECT TO
THOSE WERE SPEAKING AND I
RESPECT TO THOSE ARE WHO ARE
COMING TO TESTIFY IN PUBLIC
COMMENT SO WITH THAT.
LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO THE
CHAIR OF THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
THINK YOU CHAIR I CHIU AND I'M
DELIGHTED TO SEE SUCH A ROBUST
CROWD HERE SOMETIMES I LOOK UP
AND IT'S EMPTY AND WHEN IT'S
FULL I WONDER WE GIVING AWAY
BAGELS OR FREE BAKERY PRODUCTS
BUT TODAY WE ACTUALLY ARE GOING
TO HAVE A VERY SERIOUS --
CONVERSATION --
AND AS THE THE CHAIR MENTION
THIS IS A AN EMOTIONAL SUBJECT I
MEAN WE ARE LOOKING BEFORE US AT
ISSUES THAT DEAL WITH --
HOUSING A FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT THAT
ALL PEOPLE HAVE --
BUT WITH THAT IN MIND --
ARE JOB TODAY IS THIS IS A
CHURCH YOU MENTIONED.
I IS TO JUST SIMPLY CONSIDER
WHETHER THERE IS ANY ROLE FOR US
AS A LEGISLATURE BEFORE THE
MATTER REACHES THE BALLOT BOX.
AND THE ONLY POSSIBLE OUTCOMES
WOULD OTHERWISE BE ALL OR
NOTHING SO THE QUESTION THAT WE
HAVE TO ASK IS ARE THERE
OPPORTUNITIES HERE FOR
INNOVATION --
CAN WE COME TOGETHER PERHAPS
AROUND ALTERNATIVE SOLUTIONS
THAT EVERYONE CAN SUPPORT A OR
IS OUR COMMON GROUND THAT THAT
IS OUR JOB AND AS I MENTIONED I
KNOW THAT THIS IS A VERY --
CHARGED THE SUBJECT --
AND WE EXPECT STRONG FEELINGS
THAT THAT WE KNOW THEY'RE BEEN
STRONG DISAGREEMENTS ON THIS
TOPIC.
AND JOB I'D LIKE TO SUGGEST
BECAUSE WE CANNOT SUPPORT HAVING
INTERFERENCE IF YOU LIKE
SOMETHING.
I'VE LEARNED FROM YOUNG PEOPLE
THIS IS A WAY THAT CLAP.
AND IT WORKS --
THE SO THAT WE CAN STILL
CONTINUE WITH OUR HEARING AND
TOM.
AGAIN RECOGNIZING AS WE DO THAT
ARE ROLL HERE TODAY IS SOMEWHAT
LIMITED BUT THIS IS A CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND I A UP
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
EVERYONE'S HERE I MADE INDICATE
I'VE GOTTA RUN IN AND OUT A BIT
AND I MAY NOT BE ABLE TO STAY
FOR PUBLIC.
COMMENT --
TODAY'S MY WEDDING ANNIVERSARY
AND I PROMISED MY HUSBAND I
WOULD TRY TO GET HOME. TO HELP
CELEBRATE HIS HIS NUMBER THIRTY
SEVEN AND YOU KNOW YOU HAVE TO
WORK HARD TO GET TO THAT HIGH A
NUMBER.
EITHER THAT OR YOU HAVE TO GET
OLD.
AND I CAN SAY TO BOTH OF THOSE
BUT WITH THAT I WANT TO THANK.
I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
ALL OF YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AGAIN I
WANT TO REITERATE --
THAT WE ARE ONLY GOING TO HEAR
FROM ONE PERSON AT A TIME SO AND
THOSE WILL BE THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE ON THE MIKES ARE EITHER
AT THE DYESS.
OR ON THE PUBLIC COMMENT
ALTHOUGH I THINK JAZZ HANDS FOR
A CENTER HAD BETH JACKSON FOR
HER WEDDING ANNIVERSARY ARE VERY
APPROPRIATE.
UP WITH THAT WE DO HAVE --
TO MEMBERS FROM THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE ON OUR
CENTERS MORE LOCK OR WHITE HOUSE
IF YOU HAVE ANY OPENING COMMENTS
CENTER MORE LUCK THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IS A JUST HAD.
LIKE SORT OF A QUESTION FOR
BACKGROUND PURPOSES.
OWN RITUAL PROPERTY.
HOW MANY OF US ON THE PANEL OWN
RENTAL PROPERTY I DO NOT KNOW
THAT?
I I DO NOT I DO NOT.
HAVE YOU EVER HAD RENTAL
PROPERTY IN THE PAST.
I HAVE BEEN A RENTER.
THAT I I WOULD I WAS A WRITER
FOR FOR MONTHS AGAIN I ASK.
FOR NO COMMENTS UNLESS YOU ARE
AT A MICROPHONE THANK YOU I
WOULD JUST MAKE AN OBSERVATION
THAT I DID.
YOUNG MAN WHEN I WAS YOUR AGE
DAVID OUT SENATE ARMY OFFICER
MOVEMENT YOU.
I HAVE RENTAL PROPERTY AND IT
SAYS SPECIAL CALLING --
TOO HOPE WE FILL UP YOUR
APARTMENT --
BUILDING AND KEEP IT MAINTAINED
AND SO THERE'S A REAL SPECIAL
PERSONALITY THAT THAT IT TAKES
TO BE A LANDLORD IT'S NOT AN
EASY.
JOBS ARE.
JUST ONE ACCOUNT.
PROVIDE THAT PERSPECTIVE AS WE
ENJOY TODAY SESSION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR WHY BECAUSE ANY
COMMENTS.
AND AND I WOULD JUST SAY IN
RESPONSE TO CENTER MORE LOCK --
WE ALL KNOW AND I THINK WE ALL
WOULD AGREE THAT OUR STATE IS IN
THE MOST INTENSE.
HOUSING CRISIS EVER IN OUR STATE
HISTORY THE MOST INTENSE TENER
CRISIS IN OUR SEATS HISTORY MOST
INTENT EVICTION CRISIS IN OUR
STATE'S HISTORY.
I'M I SUPPORTED LEGISLATION THAT --
THAT WAS A SIMILAR POST --
THAT IS LEGISLATION THAT DID NOT
MOVE FORWARD IN THIS LEGISLATURE
OUT WE HAVE A BALLOT MEASURE IN
FRONT OF US.
LIKE CENTER JACKSON --
I THINK THEY'RE MANY OF US WOULD
HOPE THAT WE BE ABLE TO RESOLVE
THESE ISSUES HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE BUT IT LOOKS LIKE
THAT MAY NOT COME TO PASS --
AND SO WE HAVE A BALLOT MEASURE
AND IT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY AS
MEMBERS OF THESE COMMITTEES TO
HOLD THIS HEARING SO THAT THE
PUBLIC CAN UNDERSTAND WHAT THIS
BELT MEASURE COULD ENTAIL.
ARE AND CAN HELP MAKE DECISIONS
AROUND IT SO WITHOUT A LESSER
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
AND WE WILL PROCEED TO OUR FIRST
PANEL I'D LIKE TO ASK --
BRAIN YOU ARE FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE IF
YOU COULD PLEASE COME TO THE
DYESS -- HE
IS THE PRINCIPAL FISCAL POLICY
ANALYST FOR THE ALEJO HE WILL
PROVIDE AND THE NEXT AN OVERVIEW
THE INITIATIVE AS WELL AS AN
EVALUATION OF THE FISCAL IMPACTS
OF THIS --
AND ALTERNATE OVER TO YOU.
YES I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR
GRANULAR FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND I YOU DID
TOUCH ON THIS A LITTLE BIT BUT I
WANTED TO START OFF WITH A
LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT IN OUR ON
OUR OFFICES ROLE IN THE
INITIATIVE PROCESS.
WHICH IS A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
FROM OUR ROLE IN THE POLICY OF
THE BUDGET PROCESS WHERE WE
OFTEN --
MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS OR COMMENT
ON THE MERITS OF POLICY CHANGES
THE ROLE GIVEN US BUT GIVEN TO
US BY THE VOTERS AND THE
INITIATIVE PROCESS --
IS TO BE AN OBJECTIVE IMPARTIAL
THIRD PARTY OTHER FOCUSES ON
EVALUATING THE FISCAL EFFECTS OF
A MEASURE WITHOUT TAKING ANY
POSITION.
ON THE MERITS OF THE POLICY
CHANGE AND SO WITH THAT IN MIND
I PREPARED A PRESENTATION FOR
THE COMMITTEES TODAY.
OTHER WHILE FOR SOME --
CONTEXT IN BACKGROUND A FOR THE
MEASURE DESCRIBED THE KEY
ASPECTS OF THE MEASURE AND
SUMMARIZE OUR FISCAL ANALYSIS.
STARTING WITH THE BACKGROUND --
RENTAL HOUSING CALIFORNIA IS
EXPENSIVE --
THE TYPICAL RETURN CALIFORNIA
PAYS ABOUT 50% MORE THAN THE
TYPICAL RETURN THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY AND IN SOME PARTS OF THE
STATE.
RENTS ARE MORE THAN DOUBLE --
WHAT THEY ARE THE THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE --
IN HIGH HOUSING COSTS ARE NOT A
RECENT PHENOMENON AS EARLY AS
THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
STRUGGLED WITH HOW TO ADDRESS.
HIGH HOUSING COSTS AND IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES AND EIGHTIES
SEVERAL COMMUNITIES INCLUDING
SEVERAL LARGE CITIES SUCH AS LA.
SAN FRANCISCO AND SAN JOSE
ADOPTED LAWS KNOWN AS RENT
CONTROL OR RENT STABILIZATION
THAT LIMIT HOW MUCH RENTS
LANDLORDS CAN INCREASE RENTS.
FROM ONE YEAR TO THE NEXT AND
OFTEN RING INCREASES ARE PAID TO
SOME MEASURE OF INFLATION.
SUCH AS THE CONSUMER PRICE INDEX.
TODAY ABOUT 20% OF THE STATE'S
RENTAL HOUSING STOCK FALLS UNDER
SOME SORT OF LOCAL RENT CONTROL.
OF FOLLOWING THEPASSAGE OF THIS
COLLECTION OF RENT CONTROL
MEASURES IN THE SEVENTIES AND
EIGHTIES --
BOTH ACTIONS BY THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AND BY THE COURTS OF
PLAY SOME --
LIMITS ON THE SCOPE OF LOCAL
RENT CONTROL LAWS.
IN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED THE COSTA
HAWKINS RENTAL HOUSING ACT WHICH
PLACED THREE A KEY LIMITS ON THE
LOCAL RENT CONTROL.
FIRST IT'S A LOCAL RENT CONTROL
CANNOT APPLY TO ANY SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES.
A SECOND LOCAL RENT CONTROL
CANNOT APPLY TO ANY NEWLY BUILT
HOUSING --
COMPLETED HONOR AFTER FEBRUARY
FIRST.
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE AND FINALLY
COSTA HAWKINS REQUIRED WHAT IS
KNOWN AS VACANCY TO CONTROL
WHICH MEANS THAT A LANDLORD MUST
BE FREE TO RESET RENTS TO MARKET
RATES WHEN TRANSITIONING FROM
ONE TEN IT --
TO THE NEXT.
COURT RULINGS OF ALSO PLAY SOME
LIMITATIONS ON THE SCOPE OF
LOCAL RENT CONTROL SPECIFICALLY
A COLLECTION OF RULINGS HAS
REQUIRED THAT LANDLORDS A BE
ABLE TO RECEIVE A SO CALLED FAIR
RATE OF RETURN.
AND WHILE THE DEFINITION OF FAIR
RATE OF RETURN IS A BIT
AMBIGUOUS IN CONTEXT SPECIFIC I
THINK THE THE GENERAL IDEA --
IS THAT RENTS BE ALLOWED TO
INCREASE A SUFFICIENT AMOUNT TO
ALLOW THE LANGUAGE RETURNED TO
NOT BE ERODED OVER TIME --
BY INFLATION.
SO TURNING TO THE CHANGES
PROPOSED BY THE MEASURE THERE
ARE TWO KEY CHANGES FIRST IS TO
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS IN ITS
ENTIRETY --
THIS WOULD ALLOW --
LOCAL ENTITIES TO IMPOSE RENT
CONTROL ON SINGLE FAMILY HOMES.
OR HOMES CONSTRUCTED --
AFTER.
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE IT WOULD
ALSO ALLOW LOCAL ORDINANCES TO
INCORPORATE VACANCY CONTROL
WHICH WOULD LIMIT HOW MUCH RENTS
COULD INCREASE --
WHEN TRANSITIONING A RENTAL UNIT
FROM ONE TENANT? TO THE NEXT.
OF THE OTHER CHANGE IN THE
MEASURE IS TO PLACE INTO STATUTE
THE REQUIREMENT THAT LANDLORDS --
BE ABLE TO RECEIVE A FAIR RATE
OF RETURN --
IN THIS IS LARGELY CODIFYING THE
RESULT OF THE PAST COURT RULINGS --
THAT I MENTIONED.
I FINALLY TURNING TO OF THE
SUMMARY OF OUR ANALYSIS OF THE
MEASURES FISCAL FAX.
I WANNA START WITH A COUNTY ARE
THAT WE'RE STILL FINALIZING OUR
ANALYSIS THAT WILL SHOW UP IN
THE VOTER GUIDE IN THE NOVEMBER
ELECTION VOTER MATERIALS --
AND SO WHAT I'M ABOUT TO DISCUSS
OUR OUR OUR PRELIMINARY RESULTS
WHICH ARE LARGELY BASED ON THE
ANALYSIS WE UNDERTOOK BACK IN
THE WINNER.
WHEN THIS MEASURE WAS THAT THE
TITLE AND SUMMARY STAGE --
WITHOUT IN MIND THE THE ECONOMIC
AND FISCAL EFFECTS OF THE
MEASURE WOULD DEPEND A LARGELY
ON FUTURE ACTIONS TAKEN BY --
CITIES AND COUNTIES.
REPEALING COSTA HAWKINS IN AND
OF ITSELF DOESN'T MAKE ANY
CHANGES TO LOCAL RENT CONTROL
ORDINANCES --
IF THERE WAS GOING TO BE ANY
EXPANSION OR CREATION A NEW RING
CONTROL RULES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
THAT WOULD TAKE.
ADDITIONAL ACTIONS FROM LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
THAT BEING SAID SHOULD
COMMUNITIES RESPOND TO THIS
MEASURE BY EXPANDING OR BY
IMPLEMENTING NEW RENT CONTROL
RULES.
OF THAT HAVE A VARIETY OF
ECONOMIC AND FISCAL FAX --
BASED ON THE ECONOMIC RESEARCH
OF THE MOST LIKELY ECONOMIC
EFFECTS ARE THE FOLLOWING FIRST
SOME LANDLORDS --
WOULD CONVERT THEIR RENTAL
PROPERTIES TWO CONDOS OR OTHER
FORMS OF OWNERSHIP HOUSING IN
THIS WOULD SHIFT THE COMPOSITION
OF THE HOUSING STOCK IN ANY
COMMUNITY REDUCING THE NUMBER OF
RENTALS AVAILABLE.
AND INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
UNITS THAT ARE FOR SALE --
SECOND THE VALUE OF RENTAL
HOUSING WOULD DECLINE AS
PROSPECTIVE LANDLORDS WOULD BE
WILLING TO PAY LESS FOR RENT
CONTROLLED --
UNITS.
A THIRD A SO RENTERS IN RENT
CONTROLLED UNITS WOULD SPEND
LESS ON RENTS AND THEIR
LANDLORDS WOULD RECEIVE LESS
[inaudible]
RENTAL INCOME.
AND FINALLY RENTERS WOULD --
MOVE LESS OFTEN THIS WOULD
INCLUDE --
FEWER INVOLUNTARY MOVES --
WHERE RENTERS --
ARE ESSENTIALLY FORCED TO MOVE
BY A RENT INCREASE THAT THEY
CAN'T AFFORD AND IT COULD ALSO
INCLUDE --
SUMMER TRIPS FOR GOING A MOVE
THAT MAY BE OTHERWISE ADVANTAGES
FOR THEM TO MOVE CLOSER WORKER
FAMILY OF A DAY FOR GO THAT MOVE
TO MAINTAIN THE RELATIVELY LOW
RENT OF THEIR RENT CONTROLLED
[inaudible]
UNIT.
OF THESE ECONOMIC EFFECTS COULD
HAVE A DOWNSTREAM IMPLICATIONS
FOR OF VARIOUS STATE AND LOCAL
REVENUES.
THE ULTIMATE MAGNITUDE OF THESE
EFFECTS ON STATE LOCAL REVENUES
ARE UNCLEAR IS THEY WOULD --
LARGELY DEPEND ON THAT THE TYPE
AND TIMING OF ACTIONS TAKEN BY
LOCAL COMMUNITIES IN RESPONSE TO
THE REPEAL OF COSTA HAWKINS.
HOWEVER THE IN GENERAL WE SEE
THREE MAJOR CHANGES THE STATE
LOCAL REVENUES FIRST A LANDLORDS
WOULD PAY A LET'S PROPERTY TAXES
AS THE VALUE OF THEIR RENTAL
PROPERTIES --
WOULD GO DOWN.
SECOND RANGERS WOULD HAVE
INCREASED DISPOSABLE INCOME.
SOME OF WHICH THEY WOULD SPEND
ON TAXABLE GOODS AND THIS WOULD
LEAD TO A MORE SALES TAX REVENUE.
AND FINALLY A LANDLORDS A
PERSONAL INCOME TAX PAYMENTS
WOULD CHANGE --
WHETHER OR NOT THEY WOULD GO UP
OR DOWN --
IS DIFFICULT THE SAME IT DEPENDS
SOMEWHAT ON WHETHER OR NOT
YOU'RE FOCUSING ON THE SHORT
TERM.
OR THE LONG TERM --
THAT THEIR SEVERAL MOVING PIECES
WITHIN THE PERSONAL INCOME TAX
FEES ON THE ONE HAND LANDLORDS
WOULD BE RECEIVING LESS RENTAL
INCOME AND THEREFORE THEIR
TAXABLE INCOME WOULD BE LOWER
AND THEY WOULD PAY LOWER INCOME
TAX BECAUSE OF THAT.
ON THE OTHER HAND LANDLORDS
RECEIVE A VARIETY OF DEDUCTIONS
AGAINST THEIR TAXABLE INCOME
OTHER BASED ON THE VALUE OF THE
PROPERTY SUCH AS PROPERTY TAX
DEDUCTION MORTGAGE INTEREST
DEDUCTION --
AND APPRECIATION OF ALL OF IF
LANDLORDS WERE PAYING LESS TO
ACQUIRE PROPERTY ON THIS
REDUCTION IN THESE DEDUCTIONS
WOULD IT WOULD EFFECTIVELY
INCREASE THE TAXABLE INCOME OF
LANDLORDS.
AND LEADS THEM PAYING HIGHER
INCOME TAX PAYMENTS OF THE THE
OVERALL NET EFFECT OF THESE
MOVING PIECES IS NOT CLEAR
ESPECIALLY --
AND THE LONG TERM.
TAKING ALL THE STATE AND LOCAL
REVENUE AFFECTS TOGETHER.
AGAIN THE OVERALL MAGNITUDE --
IS IS -- IS
UNCLEAR I AM WHEN LARGELY DEPEND
ON THE TYPE AND TIMING OF LOCAL
OF ACTIONS TAKEN BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FOLLOWING THE
PASSAGE OF THIS MEASURE --
AND WITH THAT I'D BE HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO ME ASK IF
THERE ANY QUESTIONS CENTER
WIECKOWSKI.
I'M ON THE CHANGES OF STATE AND
LOCAL REVENUES HELP ME OUT HERE
BECAUSE PROPERTY REAL PROPERTY
TAXES ARE SAYS BY THE COUNTY
ASSESSOR.
SOME WOULD ARGUE THAT SOME PART
IN OUR COMPLEXES HAVE BEEN
ARTIFICIALLY LOW ON THE
ASSESSMENTS BECAUSE THEY WERE
PROP THIRTEEN AND THEY'VE THEY
GOT THEY GOT A SPECIAL TREAT
BACK IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN SO IF
THEY IF THEY ACTUALLY HAD THE
AUDACITY TO GO INTO THE ASSESSOR
AND CHALLENGE THE ASSESSED VALUE
OF THEIR PROPERTY DOZEN THAT
OPEN THE DOOR FOR THE ASSESSOR
TO LOOK AT THE TRUE VALUE.
OF THAT BUILDING IF THEY'RE
GOING TO SAY THAT THEY'VE LOST
INCOME THAT COMMERCIAL
PROPERTIES WORTH LESS BECAUSE IF
I MAKE LESS IS AN ATTORNEY I
DON'T GO TO THE ASSESSMENT SAY
HEY MY BUILDINGS WORTH LESS.
WALK ME THROUGH THAT HOW THAT
WILL HELP WITH THAT WORK.
SO YOU'RE CERTAINLY RIGHT THAT --
THERE WOULD BE THERE WOULD BE
SIGNIFICANT LAG IN THE EFFECT OF
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN.
A DECLINE IN THE MARKET VALUE OF
A RENTAL PROPERTY AND THE
DECLINE IN THE ASSESSMENT OF THE
REAL PROPERTY --
AND NOT LIKE IT'S CREATED BY
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN AND
ESSENTIALLY UP FOR MOST
PROPERTIES --
EVEN IF --
YOU KNOW IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE
MEASURE PASSES THERE SOME
DECLINE IN THEIR MARKET VALUE
FOR MOST OF THOSE PROPERTIES
THEY WOULDN'T SEE A DECLINE IN
THEIR SUSSMAN BECAUSE YOU'RE
CORRECT.
MOST PROPERTIES ARE SUCH THAT
SOMETHING WELL --
THAT BEING SAID SOME PROPERTIES
WOULD TURN OVER EACH YEAR AND
AND THEIR SALE PRICE WOULD BE
LOWER THAN IT OTHERWISE WOULD BE --
AND SO THEY WOULD ESSENTIALLY BE
ENROLLED AT A LOWER SALE PRICE
AND GOING FORWARD WOULD BE TAXED
SOMEWHAT LESS THAN THEY WOULD
HAVE BEEN OTHERWISE THAT MAKE
SENSE.
TRUE BUT WOULDN'T WE GET WITH
THEM WE GET THE TRUE UP THE
FIRST TIME THAT AT SOUL BECAUSE
BECAUSE SOMEBODY IS PAYING
PROPERTY TAXES AND LET'S GO BACK
TO ITS NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN ON
A BUILDING THAT THEY FOUGHT FOR
A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THAT'S WORTH THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IN.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHOOSE IN MY AREA
SO THEN THAT FIRST PERSON THAT
PAID THAT THE THREE MILLION
DOLLARS.
THEY WOULD BE PAYING. THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN PROPERTY
TAXES WITH THE OTHER GUYS ONLY
PAN A GRAND NOW THE SECOND SALE
WHERE THAT NOW THOUGH REN HAS
BEEN.
DEPRECIATED VER AND THEY SELL
THAT THEY OFFLOAD THAT PROPERTY
FOR TWO POINT SEVEN I AGREE WITH
YOUR ANALYSIS THAT THE OUT WITH.
IN THE LARGE PICTURE BUT THE
TRUE UP OF SO MANY RENTAL
PROPERTIES THAT ARE THE MARK THE
ASSESSED VALUE SO LOW TO THE
MARKET VALUE.
YOU SEE WHAT I'M SAYING IS THAT
THAT THAT FIRST SALE IS GOING TO
BE.
A A A A POSSIBLE INCREASE IN
PROPERTY TAXES BECAUSE THEY
ARTIFICIALLY LOW THAT'S MY
OBSERVATION.
SO I THINK --
WHAT YOU'RE ARGUING I WOULD BE
TRUE IF WE EXPECTED OF THE --
THE REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS TO LEAD
TO AN INCREASE IN LANDLORDS ARE
SELLING THEIR PROPERTIES AND I
THINK SOME HAVE ARGUED THAT I
DON'T THINK IT'S THAT WE HAVE
ENOUGH -- IN
OF IT --
INCURABLE RESEARCH TO JUSTIFY
ONE ASSUMPTION OR THE OTHER IF
THERE WERE AN INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER LIMITS ON PROPERTIES I
THINK YOU WOULD BE RIGHT EVEN IF
THEY WERE SELLING FOR LESS THAN
THAT THAN THEY OTHERWISE WOULD.
JUST THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE MORE
TURNOVER.
COULD LEAD TO AN INCREASE
IMPROPER WHAT WE WOULD EVER SEE
BUT I THINK --
I WE I DON'T KNOW THAT WE HAVE
ENOUGH INFORMATION TO MAKE THAT
KIND OF ASSUMPTION [inaudible]
SAM LOOKED [inaudible]
CHAIR -- ARE
YOU LEADER.
SURE REVIEWING THE WHOLE STATE
PICTURE DID YOU LOOK AT THE
IMPACTS THAT IT MIGHT HAVE ON
OUR PENSION SYSTEMS FOR THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA.
CALPERS MCALISTER'S BECAUSE THEY
INVEST.
WHAT 10% OF THEIR PORTFOLIOS IN
REAL ESTATE?
WE WE HAVE REVIEWED SOME --
INFORMATION ON THE AFFECT ON THE
PENSION SYSTEMS --
AND BUT TO BE HONEST IT WASN'T
THE OF THE PRIMARY FOCUS OF OUR
ANALYSIS THE THE MAGNITUDE OF
THOSE IMPACTS.
SEEM RELATIVELY SMALL COMPARED
TO THE CHANGES IN THE THE MAJOR
REVENUES OTHER I MENTIONED SO
OUR FOCUS HAS BEEN KIND OF ON
THE ON THE MAJOR STATE AND LOCAL
REVENUE SOURCES --
INSTITUTIONAL INVESTORS LIKE
CALPERS HAPPEN.
STATEMENTS BELIEF IN HAVE YOU
HAD A CHANCE.
TO SEE IF THEY HAVE A OF
STATEMENT ON RENT CONTROL.
I I HAVE NOT --
REVIEWED THAT NO BUT YOU'RE
PUTTING TOGETHER A BALLOT
ANALYSIS.
MAYBE YOU COULD CHECK INTO THAT.
BECAUSE WE CERTAINLY WANT TO BE
CAREFUL THAT ARE RETIREES GET
THEIR BENEFITS OVER TIME WE
DON'T RESTRICT.
PERHAPS THE ABILITY TO GENERATE
REVENUES --
THROUGH RENTAL PROPERTIES A BITE
LARGE COMPLEXES --
AND SO.
WE MIGHT EVEN SEE CALPERS
MCALISTER'S SAYING MAYBE.
LA OR SAN FRANCISCO IS NOT
SOMEWHERE WHERE GET INVOLVED IN
THE RENTAL.
ARENA MAYBE DO IT IN INDIANA OR
SOMEWHERE ELSE AND I IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL IF YOU IF YOU WOULD.
LOOK INTO THAT AND PROVIDE.
SOME INFORMATION BECAUSE MISTER
CHAIR LOWER.
LOWER YIELDS EQUAL TIRE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THEM THEREFORE
CAN LEAD TO HIGHER TAXES FOR ALL
OF US AND SO.
THIS ISSUE AND HAVE A AN
INDIRECT --
BEARING ON ALL OF US.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU --
WITH NO FURTHER QUESTIONS I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR ANALYSIS
WITH A FOUR TIER FINAL ANALYSIS
AS THE MEASURE MOVES FORWARD.
OF AND WILL EXCUSE YOU AT THIS
TIME.
BOB I LIKE TO CALL UP OF THE
FIRST OF TWO PANELS ISN'T I
MENTION BEFORE AT WE'RE GOING TO
GIVE THIRTY MINUTES TO THE
SUPPORT SIDE AND THIRTY MINUTES
TO THE OPPOSITION SIDE.
BOTH SIDES HAVE FOUR WITNESSES
SO I LIKE TO FIRST CALL UP THE
SUPPORTERS ARE AND WE HAVE A
FOUR AND I'LL BRING YOU UP AND
ASK YOU --
TO AT TO IDENTIFY YOURSELF
INTRODUCED HERSELF AND I BELIEVE
YOU HAVE ALREADY DECIDED.
HOW YOU'RE GONNA DIVIDE UP YOUR
TIME BETWEEN THE FOUR OF YOU?
AND THE ORDER IN WHICH YOU ABOUT
.
THE BELIEVE IS AS MS EDDINGS CAN
GO FIRST [inaudible]
OKAY GREAT YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS SHERRY
HEADINGS.
ADVOCATES OF TODAY TO SPEAK
ABOUT REPEALING COSTA HAWKINS.
IT ALLOWS CITIES TO EXPAND RENT
CONTROL.
OF COULD VERY.
MUCH BENEFIT PEOPLE LIKE ME.
SINCE NINETEEN SO IT'S TWENTY
THIRTEEN I'VE LIVED IN A SINGLE
FAMILY HOME IN LOS ANGELES THAN
WESTMONT --
NEIGHBORHOOD.
MY HOUSE IS OWNED BY --
IMITATE WHICH IS ONE OF THE
LARGEST CORPORATE LANDLORDS --
WELL MY NEIGHBORHOOD IS
UNOFFICIALLY KNOWN AS DEATH
VALLEY --
BECAUSE OF THE MURDERS THAT ARE
TAKING PLACE ABOUT --
LIKE OF FORM MILE ZONE WHERE I
LIVE I LOVE MY HOME AND I LOVE
MY COMMUNITY --
EVERY SAID YEAH I SERVE DINNERS --
AT MY HOUSE MY FAMILIES AND
FRIENDS AND ANYBODY.
CAN A TEN AND ACTIVE IN MY
COMMUNITY AND ALL MY FAMILY AND
I ALSO FEED THE HOMELESS
REGULARLY.
MY DAUGHTER AND GRANDDAUGHTER
MOVED ACROSS THE STREET FROM ME
TODAY IN THE SAME NEIGHBORHOOD
AS ME AS I AM SO LEAVE IT WOULD
BE DEVASTATING --
AND IF I HAD TO LEAVE I WOULD
HAVE.
TO OF COME OUT WITH TWO MONTHS
RENTS AND YOU KNOW A DEPOSIT TO
HAVE -- TO
LOU.
I THINK HAVE BEEN ABLE TO STAND
MY WHOLE WHICH HASN'T BEEN EASY --
BUT EVERY TWO YEARS --
MY MY INVITATION HOMES HAS OF
OVER BONE LEASE RENEWAL.
AND EACH OTHER SO I'VE HAD OUR
ELISE RENEWAL I WAS OFFER A
PROPOSED FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH INCREASE.
AND I WASN'T ABLE TO DO TO PAY
THAT SO I CONTACTED MY PORTFOLIO
MANAGER AND HE WAS ABLE TO
NEGOTIATE WITH ME AFTER A WHILE.
THAT -- FOR
THE TWENTY FIFTEEN THERE
INCREASE MY RENT MY HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH.
AND THEY WOULD TWENTY SIXTEEN K.
MIKE HAD ANOTHER INCREASE --
OF A HUNDRED DOLLARS PER MONTH.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WAS A RENEWAL
TIME AND AGAIN I GOT ANOTHER
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR --
PROPOSED INCREASE PER MY I WAS
ABLE TO NEGOTIATE ONCE AGAIN
THEY OKAY WE ARE RENTAL INCREASE
OF A HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH.
AND TWENTY SIX TAMED.
A HUNDRED THOUSAND LIGHT IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND I'LL TAKE
THE NEXT HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH
COME JULY.
OF THIS YEAR --
I ASKED HOW DID THEY GET THERE --
INCREASES FOR MY PROPERTY.
AND THEY WERE ABLE TO GIVE ME
RENTS FOR A FEW HOUSES AROUND
THE NEIGHBORHOOD.
AND TELL ME THAT THIS HOUSE READ
THROUGH THIS THIS HOUSE TO
ENSURE THAT --
BUT ON THE SECOND INCREASE I'D I
CALLED THE CORPORATE IN DALLAS
AND ASKED HIM YOU KNOW IF THEY
COULD JUST YOU KNOW INFORM ME
HOW THEY TALLY IT UP
[inaudible]
AND AGAIN THEY DO IS THEY WAS
TELL ME ABOUT THE DIFFERENT
HOUSES IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD THAT
YOU KNOW THAT WERE.
SAME IS LYING SAME SQUARE
FOOTAGE AND WHAT THEY WERE
COSTING CHO.
BUT I THINK GOD I WAS ABLE TO
NEGOTIATE IN ALL MY RENTAL
INCREASE DOWN. TO WHERE I COULD
STAND MY HOME BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE.
HAVE LOST THEIR HOMES BECAUSE OF
THE INCREASES.
OF THE COSTA HAWKINS DOESN'T
CURRENTLY ALLOW WEIGHT CONTROL
TO EXPAND TO SINGLE FAMILY HOMES
LIKE MINE.
IT DESPITE OF MY PUPPY PROPERTY
BEING -- OLD
BY -- MY
PATH IS NOT ONLY BY --
I'M SORRY.
FAMILY OR SMALL IT DIDN'T.
THE PROPERTY COMPANY IS OWNED BY
ONE OF THE LARGEST --
CORPORATE LANDLORDS IF THERE IS --
I JUST WANTED A QUOTE IN JAMES
TWO FOUR IN TO IN THE BIBLE IS
IS WE HAVE NOT BECAUSE WE ASK
THAT.
AND WHILE I WAS VERY BLESSED
AGAIN LIKE I SAY TO NEGOTIATE MY
RED.
AND TO STAND MY HOME I KNOW THAT
A LOT OF PEOPLE WEREN'T ABLE TO
DO THAT.
AND I LOVE MY HOME AND IT WAS
ONE OF THE THINGS I KNOW WHEN I
TALK TO MY PORTFOLIO MANAGER.
AND I ALSO A EXPRESSED TO HIM
THE YOU KNOW ANYBODY CAN COUNT
ON THE WHOLE ON SUNDAY IN YOU'D
GET SUNDAY DINNER HILL THOUGH.
AND THAT'S THE THING I TELL
PEOPLE DAHLE KNOCK ON THE DOOR
ON A SUNDAY YOU WALKING IN
BECAUSE YOUR FAMILY [inaudible]
AND IT'S OLD AND THAT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY YOU KNOW WOULD
BE DEVASTATED IF I HAD TO TO
LEAVE --
WOULD WIN CONTROL.
I WOULD HAVE TO IN TWO YEARS
HAVE TO WONDER WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN.
YOU KNOWING.
TWENTY NINETEEN I LOOK FORWARD
TO THAT FVE HUNDRED DOLLAR --
INCREASE FROM MY COMING BACK AT
ME OR YOU KNOW EVEN MORE I DON'T
KNOW YOU KNOW.
SO -- I'M
ONE OF THE BEST ONES TENSE
IMITATION HOMES BEGAN FIVE YEARS
AGO I'M ONE THE ONLY ONES THOUGH
STILL.
A TENANT BEER AND I WAS ASKED
THIS YEAR TO SIGN A NEW LEASE
THAT EVERYBODY ELSE WAS ON IN MY
PORTFOLIO MANAGERS SAYS.
I WAS THE ONLY ONE IS STILL
COULD PAY MY RENT ON THE SIX OF
THEM MIGHT NOT BE LAID.
BUT AS A TWENTY SEVENTEEN I HAD
TO SIGN A NEW AGREEMENT LIKE
EVERYBODY ELSE THEY HAVE THEY
RENT PAID BY THE THIRD.
SO I HAVE BEEN UP THE PART OF
INVITATION HOME SINCE THE
BEGINNING.
A LOS -- IT
A GIANT JULY NINETEENTH LEGACY
MY RENEWAL WILL COME UP AND I
DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU KNOW IT WILL
BE AT THAT TIME --
BECAUSE ARE HAWKINS CURRENTLY
ALLOWS -- WE
COULD SHOW TO BE EXPANDED.
WELL CASA HARKEN DOESN'T
CURRENTLY ALLOW MAKE YOU TOLD ME
EXPAND IN A SINGLE FAMILY HOUSE
LIKE MY DESPITE.
MY PROBABLY MEAN OLD BY.
OF A FAMILY OR A SMALL PROPERTY
OWNER.
THE PEOPLE.
COSTA HAWKINS WAS MEANT TO
PROTECT [inaudible]
AND GIVEN THE M. SUCCESSFUL THIS
TIME AND NEGOTIATING MY RENT YOU
KNOW I WOULD TO HAVE TO MAKE
DECISIONS.
TO GO ELSEWHERE BUT AGAIN I LOVE
MY I LOVE MY HOME MY LOVE MY
COMMUNITY I LOVE THE AND A PART
OF IT.
AND I JUST YOU KNOW WOULD LOVE
TO HAVE GREAT CONTROLLED SO I
COULD STAY WHERE I AM.
BUT I WOULD LIKE THAT --
OTHER PEOPLE FOR THAT ARE HERE
TO SUPPORT COSTA HAWKINS DO
STAND IF YOU WOULD [inaudible]
NO NO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY WITH THAT --
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY LET'S
GO NOW TO THE SECOND WITNESS A
DOCTOR PETER TRACK [inaudible]
MORNING --
INVITING ME HERE.
I MANY WITH PETER DREIER I'M THE
CHAIR OF THE URBAN ENVIRONMENTAL
POLICY DEPARTMENT.
AT OCCIDENTAL COLLEGE IN LOS
ANGELES BEFORE THAT --
I WAS THE DIRECTOR OF HOUSING
FOR THE CITY OF BOSTON WHERE WE
HAVE.
WELL A WRECK CONTROL LAW.
LA I MOVED HERE IN NINETEEN
NINETY THREE AND I WAS ACTUALLY
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE IN.
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE TESTIFYING
AGAINST THE COSTA HAWKINS LAW
WHEN IT WAS FIRST PROPOSED THAT
IF YOU WERE HERE AT THE TIME SO.
YOU -- I
DON'T BLAME ANY OF YOU FOR THE
CRISIS THAT IT HAD SUED --
AS YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA OR THE
WORST HOUSING CRISIS IN THE
COUNTRY ARE HOMES.
PRICES ARE RENTS ARE ABOVE THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE --
AND HIGHER THAN EVERY OTHER
STATE EXCEPT FOR HAWAII.
HAVE THE WIDEST GAP BETWEEN
INCOMES.
AND HOUSING COSTS.
HOUSING PRICES OF ESCALATED MUCH
FASTER THAN INCOMES AND NOT
SURPRISINGLY THE HOMEOWNERSHIP
RATE IN CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
STEADILY GOING DOWN WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN IT MEANS THAT.
MANY MIDDLE INCOME RENTERS.
WHO USED TO BE HOMEOWNERS THERE
WOULD'VE BEEN HOMEOWNERS ARE NOW
COMPETING WITH WORKING CLASS?
AND LOW INCOME RENTERS FOR THE
SECURE SUPPLY.
OF RENTAL HOUSING THIS HOPPED
ACTUALLY INCREASES RENT.
UP WHICH HAVE INCREASED US SINCE
TWO THOUSAND ARE TWICE AS FAST
AS INCOMES.
IN CALIFORNIA WOULD HIDE BECAUSE
THE FAIR MARKET RENT FOR A TWO
BEDROOM APARTMENT IS A SIXTEEN
HUNDRED NINETY NINE DOLLARS A
MONTH --
FAMILY NEEDS AN INCOME OF SIXTY
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR TO
AFFORD THAT THAT'S CALLED.
THE HOUSING WAGE ARE YOU NEED AN
INCOME.
OF THIRTY TWO DOLLARS AND AN
HOUR.
JUST TO AFFORD --
THE THAT THAT FAIR MARKET RENT A
HOME MOST CALIFORNIANS DON'T
EARN ANYTHING CLOSE TO THAT --
SO FOR THAT --
TWO BEDROOM FAIR MARKET RENT
APARTMENT UP FOR THE FOR THE
HOUSING WAGE IT'S VARIES AROUND
THE STATE BUT IT'S HIGH IN
ALMOST EVERY PLACE.
IT'S OVER TWENTY DOLLARS AN HOUR
RIVERSIDE IN SACRAMENTO SALINAS
CENTER WITH OBISPO KILO COUNTY.
IT'S OVER THIRTY DOLLARS AN HOUR
IN OAKLAND AND I NOT START IN
SAN DIEGO.
SANTA ROSA SANTA ANA ANAHEIM
IRVINE LA LONG BEACH GLENDALE
SANTA BARBARA SANTA MARIA --
AND A SANTA CRUZ WATSONVILLE
IT'S OVER FORTY DOLLARS AN HOUR
THE HOUSING WAGE IN OAKLAND AND
SAN JOSE.
AND IT IS SIXTY DOLLARS AN HOUR
IN SAN FRANCISCO.
CALIFORNIA A 54% OF THE RECORDS
PAY OVER 30% OF THEIR INCOME FOR
HOUSING TO HIGHEST IN THE
COUNTRY --
AND 29% ALMOST A THIRD OF ALL
THE RENTERS AND CALIFORNIA.
SPENT OVER HALF OF THEIR INCOME
JUST TO HAVE A ROOF OVER THEIR
HEAD.
I WE'RE HERE TODAY BECAUSE COSTA
HAWKINS TOOK AWAY ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT TOOLS THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE TO ADDRESS THE
HOUSING CRISIS.
IT'S ONE OF THE MAJOR
IMPEDIMENTS CITIES ARE TO
RESPOND EFFECTIVELY TO THE YOU'D
RENT INCREASES THAT ARE
[inaudible]
STABILIZING OUR PEOPLE ARE
FAMILIES OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR
LOCAL ECONOMIES.
AND SINCE THE COSTA HAWKINS ACT
WAS PASSED IN.
NINETY FIVE THE WORD CRISIS IS
GOTTEN WORSE.
THERE ARE THREE MAJOR PROVISIONS
AS YOU'VE HEARD OF THE COSTA
HAWKINS ACT THERE ARE OBSTACLES
TO ADDRESSING THE HOUSING CRISIS.
THE FIRST IS COSTA HAWKINS
PREVENTS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM
ACTING MEANINGFUL RENT CONTROL.
BECAUSE THE KIDS AT PROHIBITS
CITIES FROM REGULATING RENTS
WHEN A UNIT BECOMES VACANT.
THIS CREATES A PERVERSE
INCENTIVE FOR A LANDLORD THREE
VIC TENANTS OFTEN BY ILLEGAL
MEANS ACCORDING HARASSED AND
THIS HAPPENS ALL OVER THE STATE.
EVEN THE STRONGEST FORMS OF RENT
CONTROL THOUGH DO NOT FREEZE
RENTS RECKON TROLL ALL HOURS.
WHEN WORDS TO STEADILY INCREASE
THEIR RENTS ON A REGULAR BASIS --
GET A FAIR RETURN BASED ON SOME
FORMULA THAT CITY SET --
WE TAKE IT FOR GRANTED THAT
GOVERNMENT CAN AND SHOULD PLAY
SOME CONTROLS ON LOCAL PUBLIC
UTILITIES ELECTRICITY GAS AND
WATER -- AND
HOUSING IS ALSO A BASIC
NECESSITY SO IT'S TIME TO
RESTORE THE ABILITY OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO REGULATE RENTS
[inaudible]
SECOND.
THE COSTA HAWKINS ACT PROHIBITS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM
REGULATING RENTS ON RENTAL
HOUSING THAT WAS BUILT AFTER.
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE COSTA
HAWKINS WAS PASSED TWENTY THREE
YEARS AGO.
BUT THE DATE FOR EXEMPTING NEW
CONSTRUCTION SO CALLED NEW
CONSTRUCTION HASN'T CHANGED
SINCE THEN.
BECAUSE THE COSTA HAWKINS IN LA --
ANY UNIT BUILDING AFTER NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT IS EXEMPT FROM ANY
RIGHT REGULATIONS BUT THE
MORTGAGES ON THESE OLDER HOUSING
RENTAL HOUSING DEVELOPMENTSHAVE
BEEN PAID OFF OR A SMALL PART.
OF THE BUILDINGS OPERATING
BUDGETS SO THERE ISN'T A SINGLE
CITY IN THE UNITED STATES WHERE
RENT CONTROL COVERS NEW
CONSTRUCTION.
EVERY CALIFORNIA CITY THAT
ADOPTED SOME FORMER RENT CONTROL.
PRIOR TO THE COSTA HAWKINS ACT.
EXEMPTED NEW CONSTRUCTION EVEN
WITHOUT THERE BEING A PRO NO
PROHIBITION ON IT.
CITY SHOULD BE ABLE TO ADOPT A
SUNSET PROVISION SO THAT SAY
TWENTY YEARS AFTER RENTAL
BUILDING IS BUILT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SHOULD HAVE THE
AUTHORITY. TO REGULATE RENTS.
THIRD THE COSTA HAWKINS ACT TIES
THE HANDS OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FROM DEALING WITH WHAT I CALL
THE BLACKSTONE PROBLEM.
SINCE THE MORTGAGE CRISIS OF TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT LARGE WALL
STREET FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS
LIKE THE GLOBAL PRIVATE EQUITY
FIRM BLACKSTONE OF GOBBLED UP
MILLIONS OF SINGLE FOR A
FORKLIFT SINGLE FAMILY HOMES.
AND CALIFORNIA IS GROUND.
ZERO IN THE WALL STREET ABSENTEE
CORPORATE WHEN OR TREND.
ABOUT ONE THIRD OF THE RENTAL
UNITS IN CALIFORNIA. TWENTY TWO
POINT TWO MILLION OUT OF SIX MY
RENTAL UNITS ARE SINGLE FAMILY
BUILDINGS.
SO LOCAL JURISDICTION SHOULD BE
ABLE TO REGULATE RENTS FOR A
LARGE CORPORATE ABSENTEE
LANDLORDS WITH LARGE INVENTORIES
OF SINGLE FAMILY HOMES.
WE GIVE YOU FIVE REASONS FOR
REPEALING COSTA HAWKINS --
THE LA OH REPORT DOWNPLAYS THE
POSITIVE ECONOMIC IMPACTS AND
THE COST SAVINGS OF CITIES ADOPT
STRONGER RENT CONTROL SO WHAT
THE HIGHWAY WHAT I CONSIDER TO
BE THE FIVE ABOUT REASONS TO
REPEAL IT FIRST.
RENT CONTROL IS GOOD FOR THE
ECONOMY.
IT WILL PUT MONEY BACK IN THE
LOCAL ECONOMY --
IF UP MANY WORDS ARE OF LIMITED
FROM EXCESSIVE RATE INCREASES
TENANTS WILL HAVE MORE MONEY TO
SPEND.
THEY WILL SPEND ALMOST ALL OF
THEIR MONEY IN THE LOCAL ECONOMY
DOUBLE BOOST LOCAL BUSINESSES
INCREASE LOCAL SALES TAXES.
AND INCREASED JOBS FOR
BUSINESSES TO PROSPER AS A
RESULT OF THE ADDITIONAL
CONSUMER DEMAND [inaudible]
ALSO CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS CANNOT
THRIVE IF PEOPLE CAN'T FIND A
PLACE TO LIVE CLOSE TO WORK.
CALIFORNIA WORKERS ARE MOVING
FURTHER AND FURTHER AWAY FROM
THEIR JOBS IT'S HARD TO ATTRACT
PEOPLE TO COME TO CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE OF THE HIGH COST OF
RENTAL AND HOME OWNERSHIP
HOUSING FOR EXAMPLE I RECENTLY
CONDUCTED.
A SURVEY OF DISNEYLAND EMPLOYEES
THAT IN ANAHEIM ON ALMOST ONE
THIRD OF THEM COMMUTE MORE THAN
TWO HOURS A DAY GETTING TO AND
FROM WORK.
THAT'S BECAUSE OF THE HIGH COST
OF HOUSING IN ORANGE COUNTY
[inaudible]
SECOND REASON.
DEVELOPERS MAY NOT REALIZE HOW
RENT CONTROL ACTUALLY INCREASES
THE DEMAND FOR NEW DEVELOPMENTS
IF CITIES HAVE RENT CONTROL THE
PROTECT TENANTS IN EXISTING
BUILDINGS.
THE YOU HAVE TO BUILD MORE FOR
THE AFFLUENT TENANTS WHO WANT TO
MOVE INTO THE AREA RENT CONTROL
ENCOURAGES NEW CONSTRUCTION BY
CHANNELING HIGHER INCOME WORKERS.
INTO THE MARKET FOR NEWLY BUILT
APARTMENTS RATHER THAN ALLOWING
THEM TO DISPLACE THE SITTING
TENANTS FROM EXISTING HOUSING
[inaudible]
THIRD.
pRENT CONTROL WILL SAVE MANY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AS WELL AS THE
STATE GOVERNMENT A GREAT DEAL OF
MONEY THAT THEY NOW SPEND
ADDRESSING THE GROWING PROBLEM
OF HOMELESSNESS.
IT IS WELL KNOWN THAT IT IS LESS
COSTLY TO PREVENT A PROBLEM THEN
TO ADDRESS IT AFTER IT HAS
BECOME A SERIOUS CRISIS.
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
GOVERNMENTS SPEND A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF FUNDING ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
EMERGENCY SHELTERS AND OTHER
EFFORTS TO DEAL WITH
HOMELESSNESS IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN LA COUNTY.
CLOSE TO A BILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR CARING FOR AND MANAGING
HOMELESS PEOPLE INCLUDING HEALTH
CARE NEED SOCIAL SERVICES AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
ZILLOW RECENTLY DID A STUDY THAT
SHOWED THAT A 5% RENT INCREASE
IN LA COUNTY CARTON ADDITIONAL
TWO THOUSAND PEOPLE TO LOSE
THEIR HOMES.
SO BY REDUCING HOMELESSNESS RENT
CONTROL REDUCE THE SIGNIFICANT
COSTS TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
[inaudible]
FOURTH APPEALING COSTA HAWKINS
WOULD GIVE LOCAL GOVERNMENT THE
ABILITY TO REDUCE A GREAT DEAL
OF HUMAN SUFFERING RISING RENTS
HAVE CAUSED WIDESPREAD EVICTION.
DISPLACEMENT AND DISRUPTION OF
FAMILIES WIVES AND THERE'S A LOT
OF SOCIAL SCIENCE RESEARCH THAT
UNANIMOUSLY AGREES.
THAT HOUSING INSECURITY AND
INSTABILITY EVICTION AN
INVOLUNTARY MOVING HAS SERIOUS
AND HARMFUL PHYSICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH EFFECTS ON ADULTS AND
CHILDREN ALIKE.
CHILDREN WHO MOVE FREQUENTLY
ACCUSE ME WHO MOVE FREQUENTLY
DON'T DO AS WELL IN SCHOOL.
HOUSING INTENSELY IN SECURITY
AND STABILITY HURTS WORKERS
PERFORMANCE ON THE JOB
[inaudible]
SO.
A RECENT STUDY BY THREE
ECONOMISTS AT STANFORD FOUND
THAT RENT REGULATIONS IN SAN
FRANCISCO ENABLE THOUSANDS OF
LOWER INCOME TENANTS TO REMAIN
IN THE CITY WOULD OTHERWISE.
BEEN DISPLACED AND REDUCE THAT
THE ALMOST POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS
THAT COMES FROM BEING AFRAID OF
BEING A VICTIM OR BEING EVICTED --
AND AND WINDING UP ON THE STREET
OR NOT KNOWING WHERE YOU'RE
GOING AND FINALLY.
REPEALING COSTA HAWKINS IS ABOUT
LOCAL CONTROL OF THE HEART COSTA
HAWKINS ACT WAS REPEALED LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS RE ABLE TO DECIDE
FOR THEMSELVES WHAT KIND OF
REGULATIONS IF ANY. TO ADOPT SO
WHAT TALK ABOUT CHIU MYTHS ABOUT
RENT CONTROL THAT THE LANDLORD
Y. WE HAS CONTINUED. TO
PERPETUATE. TO DISCREDIT RENT
CONTROL FIRST THE IDEA THAT RENT
CONTROL WILL HAVE A NEGATIVE
FISCAL IMPACT ON CITIES IS VERY
MISLEADING.
THE SIMPLE PASSAGE OF THE BALLOT
MEASURE TO REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
WILL HAVE NO PHYSICAL IN.
IT ALL DEPENDS ON WHAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS DO IF ANYTHING.
ANY ANALYSIS OF THE FISCAL
IMPACT ALSO HAS TO LOOK.
AT THE RESULTING INCREASE IN
SALES TAX REVENUES THE SAVINGS
TO LOCAL AND STATE GOVERNMENT
FROM THE REDUCE COST TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS.
AND THE COST OF ADDRESSING THE
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
CONSEQUENCES HOUSING INSECURITY
INSTABILITY AND DISPLACEMENT
[inaudible]
AND SECOND.
THERE'S A MYTH.
THE WEEKEND QUICKLY BUILD OUR
WAY OUT OF CALIFORNIA'S SEVERE
HOUSING CRISIS EIGHT CD PROJECTS
THAT THE STATE WILL NEED ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION NEW HOUSING
UNITS TO MEET PROJECTED.
POPULATION AND HOUSEHOLD GROWTH
THAT'S MORE THAN TWICE THE PACE
OF NEW CONSTRUCTION OVER THE
LAST TEN YEARS.
BUT EVEN THAT FIGURE IS
MISLEADING BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
INCLUDE THE NEED TO ADDRESS THE
HOUSING CONCERNS OF THOSE WHO
CAN'T AFFORD MARKET RENTS.
SO EVEN IF WE MARSHALL THE
POLITICAL WILL TO DO SO.
CONSTRUCTING NEW HOUSING THAT WE
NEED WILL TAKE DECADES AND ONLY
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND THE
PRACTICE OF RESTRICTIVE
EXCLUSIONARY ZONING THAT LIMITS
NEW HOUSING CONSTRUCTION AND IS
THE PRIMARY CAUSE.
OF THE HOUSING SHORTAGE.
SO WE CAN'T WAIT UNTIL SUPPLY
CATCHES UP.
OR TRICKLES DOWN EXCESSIVE RENT
INCREASES ARE EXTREMELY ARE
CAUSING EXTREME HARDSHIP NOW
ONLY RENT CONTROL CAN PROVIDE
SOME IMMEDIATE RELIEF.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. ONE QUARTER
OF ALL THE FAMILIES WHO WERE
ELIGIBLE FOR SUBSIDIZED HOUSING
ACCORDING TO HOOK ONLY ONE
QUARTER RECEIVE ANY HOUSING
SUBSIDY IT'S NOT AN ENTITLEMENT.
SO EVEN IF WE HAD ENOUGH FEDERAL
HOUSING VOUCHERS FOR EVERY
FAMILY THAT'S ELIGIBLE FOR A
VOUCHER WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
APARTMENTS FOR THEM TO RENT.
IT'S LIKE GIVING PEOPLE FOOD
STAMPS WHEN THE SUPERMARKET
SHELVES ARE EMPTY EXCUSE ME I
JUST WANT TO MENTION YOUR AT
YOUR PRESENTATION TIME
COLLECTIVELY ARE EGGMAN IN.
NINETEEN I HAVE A LOT OF THEIR
STUFF FOR THE A VITAL TO
PRESENTERS.
AS THE NATION WE NEED TO BUILD
MORE HOUSING BUT WE NEED TO
PRESERVE THE EXISTING SUPPLY OF
HOUSING AND RENT CONTROL IS ONE
WAY TO DO THAT THE LANDLORD
LOBBY.
HAS BEEN CRYING WOLF FOR DECADES.
ABOUT HOUSING CONSTRUCT I RENT
CONTROL AND IT'S TIME TO TELL
THE TRUTH ABOUT RENT CONTROL
IT'S NOT THE PANACEA BUT IT IS
ONE SOLUTION THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO
ADOPT THANK YOU.
WHEN I TURN IT OVER?
TO MR DAN CAL.
SCOTT WOULD ISSUE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AQABA RESTORED MORNING GOOD
MORNING --
SOME MEMBER CHIU SENATORS THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE OUT MY NAME
IS DAN CALLED I AM IN MY SECOND
TERM AYE AYES A MEMBER OF THE
OAKLAND CITY COUNCIL
REPRESENTING OPENS.
FIRST COUNCIL DISTRICT AND
AUTHOR OF OAKLAND'S TENANT
PROTECTION ORDINANCE.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE RENT CONTROL
PROTECTIONS FOR OUR RESIDENTS
ARE WHO ARE RENTERS IN OUR CITY
OR I SHOULD I SAY. FOR MANY OF
OUR RENTERS BUT NOT ALL OF THEM
DUE TO THE COSTA HAWKINS LAW
THAT PREVENTS US.
FROM PROTECTING QUITE A LARGE
NUMBER OF OUR TENANT RESIDENTS
FROM THE VERY REAL REAL RISK OF
DISPLACEMENT.
WE EVEN STRENGTHEN THOSE LAWS
LAWS LOCAL LAWS A COUPLE YEARS
AGO HOWEVER ARE READY
PROTECTIONS CAN ONLY APPLY TO
RESIDENTS WHO LIVE IN HOUSING
BUILT BEFORE NOT BEFORE.
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE AND OUR
RESIDENTS I FAMILIES WHO RENT
pINDIVIDUAL CONDOMINIUMS ARE SHUT
OUT OF RENT PROTECTIONS BECAUSE
THE COSTA HAWKINS LAW.
PREVENTS LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
FROM INCLUDING THOSE RENTAL
UNITS IN OUR LOCAL ORDINANCES.
RIGHT NOW OAKLAND GOING THROUGH
A CONSTRUCTION BOOM AND THAT'S
GREAT.
FROM I TESTED FIFTEEN THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN OAKLAND ISSUED
BUILDING PERMITS FOR OVER SEVEN
THOUSAND RESIDENTIAL UNITS AND
SOME OF THOSE UNITS ARE BELOW
MARKET AND THAT'S A GOOD THING.
BY AS MUCH AS WE'RE TRYING AS
MUCH AS WE'RE DOING --
THAT CANNOT POSSIBLY BE ENOUGH.
LIKE MANY CITIES IN LIKE MANY
SEASON CALIFORNIA OAKLAND IS
STILL SUFFERING FROM A HOUSING
CRISIS.
OVER THE PAST THREE YEARS THE
CITY OF OAKLAND PUBLISHED A
HOUSING EQUITY ROAD MAP AND A
FOLLOW UP OAKLAND ACTION AT HOME
REPORT FROM THE MAYOR'S HOUSING
CABINET WHICH I WAS HAPPY TO BE
PART OF THESE THESE REPORTS
CLEARLY SHOW.
THAT OUR SOLUTIONS ARE NOT
EITHER BUILD MORE HOUSING OR
PROTECT MENTORS FROM
DISPLACEMENT BUT RATHER THAT WE
ABSOLUTELY MUST DO BOTH.
AND WE NEED HELP.
REPEALING COSTA HAWKINS WOULD
GIVE US ONE MORE SIGNIFICANT
TOOL TO PROTECT OUR RESIDENTS
AND MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE WHO
WORK IN OUR CITY CAN LIVE IN OUR
CITY.
OAKLAND OPENS RENTS.
ARE SOME OF THE MOST RAPIDLY
INCREASING IN THE COUNTRY AS OF
MAY TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN JUST
LAST MONTH.
THE AVERAGE RENT FOR AN
APARTMENT IN OAKLAND WAS TWO
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND NINETY
EIGHT DOLLARS.
THAT'S AN EIGHT POINT 6%
INCREASE FROM THE PREVIOUS MONTH
NOT THE PREVIOUS YEAR THE
PREVIOUS MONTH.
AT OAKLAND'S HOMELESS SITUATION
LIKE MANY CITIES.
HAS ALSO BEEN VERY CHALLENGING
TO SAY THE LEAST ARE HOMELESS
POPULATION.
CLUES FORMER RENTERS IN OUR CITY
NOW LIVING IN THEIR CARS OR ON
THE STREET.
MANY WHO WORK IN OAKLAND CAN'T
AFFORD CAN'T AFFORD TO LIVE IN
OUR CITY. FOR EXAMPLE A FEW
YEARS AGO A NEW ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL TEACHER.
WHO HAD BEEN WORKING AT A PUBLIC
SCHOOL IN MY COUNCIL DISTRICT
WANTED TO LIVE IN OR ADJACENT TO
OUR CITY?
BUT COULDN'T FIND ANY PLACE TO
LIVE THAT THAT SHE COULD AFFORD.
AFTER AWHILE SHE LEFT SHE GOT A
TEACHING JOB SOMEWHERE ELSE AND
WE'VE LOST.
TOPNOTCH EDUCATOR BECAUSE OF OUR
HOUSING CRISIS AND THE RENTS THE
WAY THEY WERE [inaudible]
AND ARE.
SOME FOLKS COMMUTER OAKLAND FOR
WORK DESPITE LIVING AS FAR AS AN
HOUR OR MORE AWAY FROM OUR CITY.
THAT'S NOT GOOD FOR FAMILIES
IT'S NOT GOOD FOR OUR
ENVIRONMENT.
BUT WE ARE WORKING ON AND
HELPING TO FINANCE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS PEOPLE ARE
BEING PUSHED OUT OF THEIR HOMES
TODAY
.
THAT'S RIGHT PEEP.
THE IN THIS INITIATIVE TO REPEAL
COSTA HAWKINS WOULD GIVE US THE
ELECTED LEADERS IN OAKLAND AND
OVER A DOZEN A DOZEN OTHER
CITIES THAT HAVE SOME SORT OF
RENT CONTROL TODAY. ONE MORE
CRITICAL TOOL. TO HELP THE MANY
PEOPLE WHO WE WERE WE WERE WHO
WE REPRESENT TO ALLOW THEM TO
STAY IN THEIR HOMES.
IN OAKLAND I COULD SEE
SUPPORTING A ROLLING SYSTEM
OBRZEG CONTROL FOR WHERE AFTER
FOR EXAMPLE AFTER FIFTEEN OR
TWENTY YEARS NEWER CONSTRUCTION
WOULD EVENTUALLY FALL UNDER RENT
CONTROL.
I CAN'T TELL YOU EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENED IN OAKLAND --
SHOULD THIS INITIATIVE PASS BUT
I DO THINK I DO BELIEVE THAT WE
SHOULD AT LEAST HAVE THE OPTION
TO MAKE OUR DECISION BASED ON
WHAT WE FEEL IS BEST FOR OUR
COMMUNITY AND OUR RESIDENTS
THAT'S WHAT WE WERE ELECTED TO
DO.
I'M HERE ASKING VOTERS AND
ASKING THE LEGISLATURE IF IT'S
NOT TO LATE TO GIVE US THOSE
TOOLS.
EVEN AS WE BUILD NEW HOUSING.
WE NEED TO PROTECT OUR EXISTING
RENTERS FROM THE VERY REAL RISK
OF DISPLACEMENT.
I WAS ALSO ASKED TO NOTE.
I BY MR ORSON AG RELY OUR WHO'S
THE EXECUTIVE DRESSED DIRECTOR
OF THE GREEN LINING INSTITUTE I
WAS ASKED TO NOTE BY HIM
DIRECTLY. TO LET YOU KNOW THAT
HE AND HIS COLLEAGUES AT GREEN
LINING SUPPORT ADDITIONAL
PROTECTIONS FOR RENTERS AND
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS BALLOT
MEASURE.
PASSED IN ORDER TO REPEAL COSTA
HAWKINS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME.
IT YOU VERY MUCH AND THE FINAL
SPEAKER IS --
MR BRENT TURNER AYE --
AYE WILL JUST NOTE AT THIS TIME
YOU HAVE FIVE MORE MINUTES ON
THE THIRTY AND I'M SORRY THAT
YOU CAME AT THE END BUT THAT IS
THAT.
THANK TRIGGERED CHAIR CHIU --
SENATORS --
GOOD DAY MY NAME IS BRENT TURNER
I'VE BEEN A REAL ESTATE --
I AM A REAL ESTATE BROKER IN SAN
MATEO COUNTY I'VE BEEN IT IN
REAL ESTATE AS A LICENSED AGENT
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY AND I'VE
OWNED TURNER REAL ESTATE.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND I HAVE A PROP
FOR ME DOING BOTH RESIDENTIAL
AND COMMERCIAL REAL ESTATE
DIAMOND ECO BROKER U. S. GREEN
BUILDING COUNCIL CERTIFIED.
AND A GRADUATE OF THE REAL
ESTATE INSTITUTE I TEACH REAL
ESTATE AT THE COLLEGE LEVEL.
IN MY PERSONAL TIME I'M A
LANDLORD.
AND I'VE OWNED UP TO EIGHT
PROPERTIES IN MY PAST --
IN ALL MY YEARS IN THE INDUSTRY
I'VE SEEN MANY BOOMS AND BUSTS
IN THE HOUSING MARKET.
FROM THE FALLOUT OF THE DOT COM
BUBBLE.
IN THE EARLY TWO THOUSANDS TO
THE GREAT RECESSION TO THE
CURRENT MARKET.
I'VE I'VE COME TO THE BELIEF
THAT RENT CONTROL IS NOT ONLY
THE MORAL THING TO DO IT'S ALSO
THE SMART THING TO DO.
ACOSTA HAWKINS IS A MAJOR THOUGH
NOT THE ONLY CONTRIBUTOR TO THE
HOUSING CRISIS.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF LANDLORDS
ARE ARE GOOD ACTORS BUT COSTA
HAWKINS GIVES LATITUDE. TO THE
BAD ACTORS TO ACT POORLY AND
REPEALING IT WOULD GIVE LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES.
THE AUTHORITY TERRAIN THE MEN
AND MAKE OUR COMMUNITIES
STRONGER.
I HAVE SEEN SAN MATEO COUNTY.
OVERRUN WITHOUT OF TOWN
LANDLORDS AS OF LATE.
THEY HAVE NO RELATIONSHIP TO THE
COMMUNITY BUT THEY ARE IMPACTING
THE COMMUNITY SEVERELY.
I'VE SEEN NURSES FIREFIGHTERS
TEACHERS SERVICE WORKERS AND
THEIR CHILDREN RUN OUT OF TOWN
BECAUSE THEY CAN NO LONGER
AFFORD TO KEEP UP WITH THE HIGH
RENTS THAT ARE BEING PLACED ON
THEM.
THIS IS AN UNSUSTAINABLE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROBLEM THAT'S TO
THE DETRIMENT OF EVERYONE.
ALL IT TAKES IS ONE MARKET CRASH
WHICH WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
EVENTUALLY.
THEN YOU WILL HAVE NOBODY LIVING
IN THE COMMUNITY FOR EMERGENCIES
TO WORK IN THE COMMUNITY TO
TEACH OUR CHILDREN ACCEPT IRA.
THAT WILL SINK THE VALUE OF OUR
COMMUNITIES EVEN FURTHER HIGH
RENTS CAN'T LAST FOREVERBUT
THEY HAVE TERRIBLE CONSEQUENCES
WHEN THEY'RE ENACTED.
IN MY EXPERIENCE TOO MANY REAL
ESTATE INVESTORS BUYING HOMES
NOW ARE IN IT FOR THE SHORT TERM
GAIN NOT FOR THE TRADITIONAL
STABILITY.
THAT PURCHASING HOUSING BRINGS.
TRADITIONALLY INVEST INVESTORS
ABOUT HOUSING BECAUSE IT'S A
GOOD STABLE INVESTMENT.
THEIR PROPERTY TAXES REMAIN
STABLE BECAUSE OF PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN AND IF THEY'RE IN
DESIRABLE AREAS THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO ATTRACT AND THAT'S
FOR YEARS TO COME.
REAL ESTATE INVESTORS WILL HAVE
STABLE SOURCES OF INCOME.
WHEN REAL ESTATE INVESTORS TALK
ABOUT PAIN I THINK WE SHOULD
NECESSARILY DIFFERENTIATE THE
KIND OF PAIN THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT FROM THE PAIN OF PEOPLE?
THAT ARE IN THE PROBLEMATIC
SITUATION OF BEING THROWN INTO
THE STREET.
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH
WANTING TO MAKE A LOT OF MONEY
BUT WHEN THAT DESIRE IMPACTS
PEOPLE'S ABILITIES TO LIVE AND
WORK IN A GEOGRAPHIC THAT'S
ALREADY IN CRISIS WE HAVE A
PROBLEM.
REMEMBER THESE LANDLORDS THAT
MAY COMPLAIN A ARE ABLE TO TEN
THIRTY WHEN THEIR PROPERTIES
INTO OTHER AREAS THAT ARE NOT
SUFFERING IMMEDIATE CRISIS.
THOUGH I AM PERSONALLY NOT
IMPACTED BY RENT CONTROL AS THE
OWNER OF MY PROPERTIES I DO KEEP
MY RENT STABLE ON MY OWN
PROPERTIES BECAUSE CHANGING
TENANTS ALL THE TIME.
AND PRICE GOUGING PEOPLE IS NOT
MY IDEA OF GOOD BUSINESS.
WHEN YOU HAVE TO SWITCH BETWEEN
TENETS YOU TEND TO HAVE SOME
DEAD TIME OR VACANCY TIME?
THEN YOU HAVE TO TEND TO THE
FIXES IT YOUR PREVIOUS TENANTS
MAY NOT HAVE TOLD YOU ABOUT THEN
ONCE YOU GET A NEW TENANT YOU'RE
GUESSING IF THEY WILL BE A
PROBLEM OR NOT.
IN MY EXPERIENCE IT'S EASIER TO
LOVE THE ONES YOU'RE WITH THEN
REYES RANCH.
AND CONTINUOUSLY GET A REVOLT.
REPEALING COSTA HAWKINS SIMPLY
TURNS POWER TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES
TO MAKE DECISIONS FOR THEM AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE REALLY TALKING
ABOUT HERE PRESERVING THE POWER
OF COMMUNITIES THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
AND I THINK YOU WHEN THAT.
THE COURT OF THE DAY LOVE THE
ONES HERE WITH JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT -- WITH
THAT LET ME ASK US HUNDRED YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS TO THIS PANEL.
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION --
I THINK YOU PRESENTED --
A COMPREHENSIVE VIEW OF FROM
YOUR PERSPECTIVE AND I WILL
EXCUSE YOU AT THIS TIME.
AND WE WILL CALL UP THE PANEL --
OF MEMBERS OF THE OPPOSITION
.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US --
THE PANEL COLLECTIVELY HAVE
THIRTY MINUTES AND I THINK WE'LL
BE STARTING WITH MISS CARTON.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
UP MY NAME IS DEBORAH CARLSON I
AM THE SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT FOR
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION WE REPRESENT
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY THOUSAND
RENTAL PROPERTY OWNERS AND
MANAGERS WHO OPERATE.
APPROXIMATELY TWO MILLION UNITS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THIS MORNING I WANT TO FOCUS ON
THREE AREAS CONCERNING THE
INITIATIVE.
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING ACT.
FIRST OF ALL THE WARNINGS THAT
WE'VE RECEIVED FROM ECONOMISTS
AND THE STATE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE ABOUT THE
IMPOSITION OF STRICT RENT
CONTROL. TO ALSO THAT THIS
INITIATIVE WERE AND WHAT IT WILL
DO.
A WHEN IT COMES TO LAWSUITS AND
THE COSTS ON THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND FINALLY THE INABILITY FOR
STATE LAWMAKERS TO CORRECT ANY
PROBLEMS THAT COME AS A RESULT.
OF THE PASSAGE OF THIS
INITIATIVE.
SO FIRST THE WARNINGS.
I THERE IS NOT ONE CREDIBLE
ECONOMIST OR STUDY THAT HAS
REPORTED THAT STRINGENT RENT
CONTROL WILL HELP CALIFORNIA.
IT WON'T HELP EMPLOYERS RECRUIT
EMPLOYEES AND IT WON'T CREATE
NEW.
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
ACCORDING TO THE LA SHOW AND
OTHER STUDIES ON RENT CONTROL
THEY STRONGLY SUGGEST.
THAT THIS INITIATIVE WHICH
INTENDS TO ELIMINATE THE STATE'S
COSTA HAWKINS RENTAL HOUSING ACT
WELL REDUCE THE EXISTING STOCK
OF RENTAL HOUSING.
WILL INCREASE RENTS IN
NEIGHBORING COMMUNITIES.
WELL TURNED HOUSING OVER TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT IN NEED.
IT WILL INCREASE BLIGHT AND
HOMELESSNESS.
UNDER STRICT FORMS OF RENT
CONTROL THE STUDIES DEMONSTRATE
THE PROPERTY OWNERS WILL CONVERT
THEIR HOUSING TO OWNERSHIP
HOUSING.
CONDOMINIUMS AND TENDENCIES AND
CARMEN.
A STUDY OUT OF STANFORD
UNIVERSITY FOUND THAT SAN
FRANCISCO REDUCE TO SUPPLY.
THE MINISTER COURTESY IN THIS
HEARING ROOM.
THE SAME COURTESY THAT EACH OF
YOU WHO WOULD WANT TO SPEAK
WOULD WANT TO RECEIVE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SIR.
I STUDY OUT OF STAMFORD FOUND
THAT SAN FRANCISCO REDUCED ITS
SUPPLY RENTAL HOUSING BY 15% AND
EXPERIENCED A 25% REDUCTION IN
THE NUMBER OF RENTERS LIVING IN
RENT CONTROL UNITS TODAY
RELATIVE TO NINETEEN NINETY FOUR
LEVELS.
AND A RECENT STUDY OUT OF UC
BERKELEY THE TURN REPORT
DEMONSTRATES THAT STRICT RENT
CONTROL.
WHICH SHOULD BECOME LEGAL UNDER
THE ELIMINATION OF COSTA HAWKINS.
COULD CONSTRAIN NEW HOUSING
SUPPLY.
REDUCE INVESTMENT IN HOUSING
QUALITY.
AND WILL LEAD TO THE REMOVAL OF
THE EXISTING UNITS FROM THE
MARKET.
AND BECAUSE RATE CONTROL IS
RARELY MEANS TESTED WE KNOW THAT
THE BENEFITS DON'T COME TO THOSE
WHO TRULY NEED IT.
RENT CONTROL UNIT SHOULD BE
RESERVED FOR THOSE IN MOST NEED.
SO THAT WE DO NOT SEE
DISPLACEMENT.
UNFORTUNATELY THE INITIATIVE
DOES NOTHING TO TARGET THIS
POPULATION AND DOES NOTHING TO
PROTECT THE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
DESPERATE FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND WHO ARE LEFT OUT IN THE COLD.
THE TURNER REPORT SUGGESTS A
NUMBER OF WAYS TO EXTEND
MEANINGFUL PROTECTION TO RENTERS
WITHOUT CONSTRAINING NEW SUPPLY.
AS AN ORGANIZATION THAT
REPRESENTS RENTAL PROPERTY
OWNERS WE DO NOT WANT TO SEE
RENTAL PROPERTY OWNERS GO OUT OF
THE BUSINESS.
BUT WHEN READ CONTROL BECOMES
TOO EXTREME.
WE WILL DEFEND THEIR RIGHT TO DO
SO.
IF THIS INITIATIVE PASSES
ESPECIALLY FOR SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES AND SMALLER BUILDINGS.
SMALL OWNERS WHO REPRESENTED
MODE MAJORITY OF THE HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA WILL CONVERT FOR WILL
SELL THEIR HOMES OCCUPANTS OR
UNFORTUNATELY TO AIRBNB
SITUATIONS.
WE'VE SEEN THIS IN STRICT RENT
CONTROLLED A SITUATIONS.
THERE ARE WEBSITES DEVOTED TO
THIS AS YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD A
NUMBER OF STATE BILLS THAT
ATTEMPTED UNSUCCESSFULLY STOP
OWNERS FROM LEAVING THE MARKET.
THERE'S NO DOUBT WE ARE GOING TO
SEE MORE OF THIS [inaudible]
WE AGREE.
CALIFORNIA'S HIGH COST OF LIVING
HAS MADE IT DIFFICULT IN SOME
PARTS OF THE STATE FOR EMPLOYERS
TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN SKILLED
WORKERS.
THIS ALL CENTERS AROUND THE FACT
THAT WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
HOUSING.
NOT BECAUSE OF COSTA HAWKINS.
WE'VE ALL SEEN NEWS REPORTS THAT
TELL US THAT SOARING HOUSING
COSTS HAVE LED TO THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE LEAVING THE CALIFORNIA.
THIS WILL CONTINUE EVEN IF THE
INITIATIVE PASSES AND WHILE
EXISTING TENANTS MAY EXPERIENCE
LOWER RENTS.
IT WILL BE HARDER TO FIND A
VACANT UNIT FOR NEW EMPLOYEES
AND STUDENTS.
THE INITIATIVE DOES NOT ADDRESS
OUR HOUSING PROBLEM IT POURS
GASOLINE ON A HOUSING CRISIS AND
WE BELIEVE MAKES IT WORSE.
FINALLY THE PROPONENTS CITE THAT.
THAT STUDIES THAT SHOW THAT RENT
CONTROL COMMUNITIES.
A CONSTRUCTION HAS CONTINUED I
HAVE TO REINFORCE THE FACT THAT
NEW CONSTRUCTION HAS CONTINUED
BECAUSE COSTA HAWKINS HAS
ENSURED THAT THOSE DEVELOPERS
WILL RECEIVE IN BE EXEMPT FROM
RENT CONTROL.
THE INITIATIVE DOES NOT PROVIDE
THOSE ASSURANCES.
ON THE FRONT OF LITIGATION.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF WAYS IN
WHICH THIS INITIATIVE WILL
INCREASE LITIGATION AND COST TO
THE STATE.
SECTION TEN OF THE INITIATIVE
PROVIDES THAT IF THE STATE OR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES FAILED
TO TO A TO DEFEND THE INITIATIVE.
PROPONENTS ARE AUTHORIZED TO
INTERVENE IN ANY COURT ACTION
CHALLENGING BUT ACT'S
CONSTITUTIONALITY.
THE PROPONENTS ATTORNEY'S FEES
MUST BE SATISFIED PROMPTLY OUT
OF THE FUNDS.
A APPROPRIATED TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THIS PROVISION WILL ADD
LITIGATION COSTS IMPOSED BY THE
INITIATIVE OR STATE GOVERNMENT
BECAUSE THE INITIATIVE PROVIDES
THAT THE STATE MUST PAY THEIR
COST WHETHER THEY WIN OR LOSE.
THIS WAR KICK RECREATE A COTTAGE
INDUSTRY FOR TRIAL LAWYERS TO
LITIGATE EVEN IF THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION HAS DECIDED. TO AND
LITIGATION AND TO SETTLE.
AND WHILE THIS INITIATIVE DOES
ALLOW FOR A FAIR RETURN ON
INVESTMENT IT FAILS TO DEFINE IT.
BEFORE COSTA HAWKINS CAME INTO
EFFECT THERE WERE HUNDREDS OF
LAWSUITS ON THIS TOPIC.
AFTER COSTA HAWKINS CAME INTO
EFFECT THE LAWSUITS WERE ALL BUT
ELIMINATED.
BECAUSE IT GAVE TO LANDLORDS
VACANCY DE CONTROL.
THE LOW RANCID OWNERS WERE
REQUIRED AYE TO CHARGE UNDER
SOME EXTREME FORMS OF RENT
CONTROL.
ALSO GAVE THE THEM THE ABILITY
TO INCREASE THEIR RENTS WHEN
THERE WAS A TURNOVER INTENDANCY.
WE WILL SEE LITIGATION CONTINUE
AND PROBABLY INCREASED
DRAMATICALLY AS A RESULT OF THIS.
INITIATIVE AND OR STRICT FORMS
OF RENT CONTROL WHICH HAVE BEEN
PROMISED TO US.
BY LOCAL COMMUNITIES NOW FINALLY
THIS MEASURE PREVENTS THE
LEGISLATURE FROM ADDRESSING ANY
PROBLEMS CREATED BY THIS
INITIATIVE.
THE LANGUAGE PROVIDES THE
LEGISLATURE MAY ONLY AMEND THIS
ACT TO FURTHER THE PURPOSES OF
THE BILL.
IN EACH HOUSE TWO THIRDS OF THE
LEGISLATURE MUST.
PASS THAT IN THE GOVERNOR MUST
SIGN IT NO STATUTE RESTRICTING
OR ELIMINATING THE POWERS OF THE
OF THIS INITIATIVE MAY BE PASSED
UNLESS BY THE VOTERS.
WHICH AS YOU ALL KNOW MEANS IT
AFFECTS UNLESS ITS EFFECT IT'S
EFFECTIVE UNLESS APPROVED BY THE
MAJORITY OF THE VOTERS.
ALL OF YOU KNOW.
AS OUTLINED BY THE LA OPEN AND
THE STUDIES.
IF THE NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES
COME TO FRUITION.
YOU CAN DO NOTHING ABOUT IT
THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
FOR ALL OF THESE REASONS THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
AND MANY OTHERS LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE CONFERENCE OF
THE N. DOUBLE ACP.
THE AMERICAN LEGION DEPARTMENT
OF CALIFORNIA.
MILITARY OFFICERS OF AMERICA.
AND THAT'S DEPARTMENT OF
CALIFORNIA AMERICAN GI FORM OF
CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
HOUSING FINANCE AGENCIES AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HOUSING
AUTHORITIES WILL OPPOSE THE
INITIATIVE IN NOVEMBER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
LISTENING.
IF YOU VERY MUCH OF I WANT.
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE'VE BEEN
JOINED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RICHARD BLOOM FROM SANTA MONICA
AND WITHOUT LIKE TO MOVE TO THE
NEXT BAKER.
US AND EUROPE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
BEFORE YOU TODAY MY NAME IS
CYNTHIA RIGHT I'M THE SENIOR
DIRECTOR OF ACQUISITIONS WORKING
EXCLUSIVELY AT FPI MANAGEMENT
SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY APPLYING
MANAGEMENT IS THE LARGEST
AFFORDABLE AND CONVENTIONAL
APARTMENT MANAGEMENT COMPANY IN
CALIFORNIA WE MANAGE SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND UNITS.
THE FLAWED INITIATIVE WILL HAVE
A DEVASTATING IMPACT ON NEW
RESIDENTIAL CONSTRUCTION.
THE UNCERTAINTY REGARDING THE
FUTURE OF COSTA HAWKINS HAS
ALREADY PUT ON HOLD A NUMBER OF
NEW HOUSING PROJECTS.
THAT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON FOR
YEARS WITH THE ADDITIONAL COSTS
RELATING TO LAND AND
CONSTRUCTION THESE PROJECTS WILL
SIMPLY NOT PENCIL IF SUBJECTED
TO EXTREME AND PERMANENT RENT
CONTROL.
IN ADDITION MANY DEVELOPERS
WHILE HOLDING OFF ON DEVELOPMENT
IN CALIFORNIA ARE RAMPING UP
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS IN
NEIGHBORING STATES.
MANY LARGE DEVELOPERS TEND TO
HAVE A NATIONAL FOOTPRINT
ALREADY.
IF YOU HAVE THE SAME INVESTMENT
DOLLARS AND NO BUILDING PROJECTS
IN NEIGHBORING STATES IS MORE
PREDICTABLE.
AND CARRIES IT LAST RISK.
EXCUSE ME THERE ARE RULES IN THE
CHAMBER ABOUT NOT HAVING SIGNS
BECAUSE IT DOES BLOCK THE VIEW
OF OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
AND HOW THEY ARE ABLE.
TO NOT SEE THE PROCEEDINGS SO I
WILL ASK YOU NOT TO DISPLAY
SIGNS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BACK TO YOUR TESTIMONY THANK YOU
WE STOP THE CLOCK FOR YOU.
THANK YOU SIR IF YOU HAVE THE
SAME INVESTMENT DOLLARS AND NO
BUILDING PROJECTS IN NEIGHBORING
STATES IS MORE PREDICTABLE AND
CARRIES LESS RISK THINK CLEARLY
YOU WILL DEVELOP AND OTHER
STATES.
I RECENTLY TOWARD A NEW TWO
HUNDRED UNIT COMMUNITY IN A
NEIGHBORING STATE THAT CAME OUT
OF THE GROUND IN TWO YEARS.
THIS TWO HUNDRED UNIT COMMUNITY
WHICH DOES HAVE AN AFFORDABLE
COMPONENT.
BY CAL IS BEING PURCHASED BY
CALIFORNIA BASED COMPANY TAKING
INVESTMENT DOLLARS OUT OF THE
STATE IN CALIFORNIA IT TAKES
FIVE TO TEN YEARS TO GET
PROJECTS OUT OF THE GROUND.
AS THERE'S A SHORTAGE OF
AFFORDABLE AND AVAILABLE HOUSING
IN THE BAY AREA THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY HAS NOW BECOME THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SOLUTION FOR
THE BAY AREA.
WITH THE INCREASE OF RENTERS I'M
SEEING VACANCY RATES DECREASE
AND A NEED FOR MORE HOUSING IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF EXTREME
RENT CONTROL AND THE BAY AREA
WILL HAVE AN IMPACT ON THESE
VALLEY TOWNS.
THE VALLEY IS ALREADY THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SOLUTION FOR
THE BAY AREA AS WITNESSED BY THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO HAD WEST
OVER THE ALTAMONT IN DETAIL
PASSES TO WORK.
UNFORTUNATELY THE IMPACT OF THE
FLAWED INITIATIVE HAS A CHILLING
EFFECT OF A HOUSING FREEZE SOME
OF MY CLIENTS ARE PUTTING ON
HOLD THEIR DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS
IN THE VALLEY.
PENDING THE OUTCOME OF THE
INITIATIVE.
I HAVE HONOR CLIENTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE THAT FIND THEMSELVES
IN SIMILAR SITUATIONS EITHER
SLOWING DOWN PROJECTS OR
RECONSIDERING THEM IN THE LIGHT
OF THE UNCERTAINTY AROUND COSTA
HAWKINS.
AT THE SAME TIME MANY BUILDINGS
NEED RENOVATION IN ORDER TO KEEP
THEM RELEVANT FUNCTIONAL AND IN
THE CURRENT HOUSING STOCK.
INSTEAD OF PLANNING FOR
RENOVATIONS CLIENTS ARE LOOKING
AT CONVERSIONS AND SALE OF THEIR
PROPERTIES.
THESE RENOVATIONS WOULD HAVE
PROVIDED LOCAL JOBS TAX REVENUE
DOLLARS AND WOULD HELP PRESERVE
AND STRENGTHEN THE COMMUNITIES
LOCAL ECONOMY.
AS A COMPANY WE CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE THE AFFORDABILITY
CHALLENGES THAT CALIFORNIANS
FACE OUR COMPANY AND PARTNERS
WANT TO CONTINUE TO INVEST IN DO
BUSINESS IN THE STATE.
BUT THIS WILL HAVE A DEVASTATING
IMPACT IN THE LONG RUN IT WILL
LEAD TO SIGNIFICANTLY FEWER NEW
AND AFFORDABLE RENTAL UNITS IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE NEED TO FOCUS ON POLICIES
THAT HELPS LIKE THE LOCAL
HOUSING BOND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET'S GO [inaudible]
TO THANK YOU.
IT'S GOT A MISTER GREASY.
HOW GOOD MORNING --
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ARE GOOD
AFTERNOON RATHER --
CREAM GREASY ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS AS
OPPOSED TO THE INITIATIVE BEING
DISCUSSED BEFORE YOU TODAY.
SEE OUR CO SPONSORED THE COSTA
HAWKINS RENTAL HOUSING ACT IN
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE WHICH IS A
BIPARTISAN COMPROMISE PASSED BY
THE LEGISLATURE IN RESPONSE TO
THE PROLIFERATION OF EXTREME
RENT CONTROL.
THIS INITIATIVE AMONG OTHER
THINGS SEEKS TO REPEAL THE
ENTIRETY OF THAT ACT.
THE PROPONENTS OF THIS
INITIATIVE A PROFFER THE
ARGUMENT THAT THE REPEAL OF
COSTA HAWKINS WILL HELP
ALLEVIATE THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CRISIS.
WE STRONGLY DISAGREE WITH THIS
CONTENTION AND TO THE CONTRARY
BELIEVE THAT THE REPEAL OF COSTA
HAWKINS WILL MAKE THE STATE'S
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY CRISIS
EVEN WORSE [inaudible]
SPECIFICALLY.
IF COST AUDIENCES REPEAL THIS
RESULT IN THE PASSAGE OF THIS
INITIATIVE CLOSE TO TWO POINT
TWO MILLION SINGLE FAMILY
RENTALS AND APPROXIMATELY.
HUNDRED EIGHTY FOR APPROXIMATELY
HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND MULTI FAMILY
UNITS BUILT AFTER.
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE COULD BE SUBJECTED TO
UNREAD UNBRIDLED RENT CONTROL
POLICIES.
IF THIS INITIATIVE IS PASSED IN
NOVEMBER APPROXIMATELY THREE
MILLION UNITS ABOUT 23% OF THE
HOUSING STOCK IN CALIFORNIA.
COULD BE SUBJECTED TO LIMIT WAS
RENT CONTROL.
SUBJECTING CLOSE TO A QUARTER OF
THE HOUSING STOCK IN THE STATE
TO EXTREME RENT CONTROL WOULD
HAVE DISASTROUS CONSEQUENCES.
MOST NOTABLY IT WOULD
DRASTICALLY REDUCED AMOUNT OF
SINGLE FAMILY RENTALS THESE
RENTAL PROPERTY OWNERS A VAST
MAJORITY OF WHOM ARE SMALL MOM
AND POP OPERATORS.
WOULD BE UNABLE TO MAINTAIN
THEIR PROPERTIES UNDER THE DIRE
FINANCIAL CONSTRAINTS IMPOSED BY
EXTREME RENT CONTROL.
AS A RESULT THE SINGLE FAMILY
RENTALS TO BE SOLD AND CONVERTED
TO OWNER OCCUPIED PROPERTIES
FURTHER EXACERBATING THE STATE'S
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY CRISIS.
IN TERMS OF THE IMPACTS OF
EXTREME RENT CONTROL ON NEW
CONSTRUCTION A RECENT STUDY FROM
RECORDS UNIVERSITY INCLUDED A
CROSS SECTIONAL ANALYSIS OF NEW
JERSEY METROS WITHIN WITHOUT
RENT CONTROL.
AND FOUND THAT PER CAPITA
CONSTRUCTION FALLS BY ABOUT 25%
IN JURISDICTIONS WITH RENT
CONTROL HOLDING ALL OTHER
VARIABLES CONSTANT.
APPLYING THAT RESULT CALIFORNIA.
INSTRUCTION WOULD DECREASE BY
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND UNITS
PER YEAR AND WOULD LEAD TO A
CUMULATIVE DEFICIT OF WELL OVER
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND UNITS BY.
TWENTY THIRTY ADDITIONALLY THE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF EXTREME RENT
CONTROL CAN BE SEEN FROM LOOKING
AT SUCH RENT CONTROL AS IT
EXISTED PRIOR TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF COSTA HAWKINS.
IN BERKELEY DURING THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES EXTREME RENT CONTROL
WAS IMPOSED ON SINGLE FAMILY
RENTALS IN NEW CONSTRUCTION.
AS A RESULT BERKELEY REPORTED
THAT ABOUT THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED
UNITS THAT WERE RENTED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY WERE NOT RENTED
A DECADE LATER IN PART BECAUSE
TWELVE HUNDRED SINGLE FAMILY
RENTALS AND SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MULTI FAMILY UNITS WERE
CONVERTED OWNER OCCUPANCY.
THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF EXTREME
RENT CONTROL OF NOT JUST
EXCLUSIVE TO CALIFORNIA.
THE CITY OF CAMBRIDG
MASSACHUSETTS FOUND THAT EXTREME
RENT CONTROL IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES RESULTED IN ROUGHLY
10% OF THE CITY'S RENT CONTROL
HOUSING STOCK.
BEING CONVERTED TO NON
CONTROLLED CONDOMINIUMS.
IN RESPONSE TO THIS AND OTHER
FINDINGS CAMBRIDGE EVENTUALLY
VOTED TO ELIMINATE EXTREME RENT
CONTROL IN.
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR GIVEN ALL
THIS EXTREME RENT CONTROL WHICH
WOULD RETURN TO CALIFORNIA THIS
INITIATIVE PASSES.
CLEARLY NOT THE SOLUTION THE
STATE'S HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS.
RATHER THE SOLUTION IS MORE
SUPPLY.
THERE'S SIMPLY NO GETTING AROUND
IT CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
SUFFER FROM A STAGGERING AND
CHRONIC HOUSING SUPPLY SHORTAGE.
THE STATE IS NOT SIMPLY BUILDING
ENOUGH HOUSING UNITS FOR
EVERYONE.
THE LACK OF ADEQUATE SUPPLY HAS
LED TO SKYROCKETING PRICES.
CLEARLY SUBSTANTIALLY MORE
HOUSING NEEDS TO BE BUILT.
HERE'S SOME TROUBLING FACTS FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THREE POINT
FOUR MILLION ADDITIONAL HOUSING
UNITS ARE NEEDED BY.
TWENTY THIRTY ABOUT HALF THE
NATIONAL HOUSING UNITS IN
CALIFORNIA. TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT SAYS THAT
THE STATE MUST BUILD HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND UNITS EACH YEAR
TO KEEP PACE WITH POPULATION
GROWTH.
THE STATE IS CURRENTLY ONLY
BUILDING HALF THAT. THREE THE
STATE'S MEDIAN HOME PRICE IN MAY
OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN OF
600-100-0800 SIXTY DOLLARS IS
MORE THAN DOUBLE THE NATION'S
MEDIAN PRICE.
AVERAGE HOME RENTALS ARE 50%
HIGHER THAN THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY.
AND LASTLY THE STATE'S
HOMEOWNERSHIP RATE OF FIFTY FIVE
POINT 1% IS THE SECOND LOWEST
AMONG ALL STATES IN THE U. S..
CA ARE PROPOSES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER THE
FOLLOWING TO HELP INCREASE THE
STATE'S HOUSING SUPPLY. ONE
STREAMLINE THE PERMITTING
PROCESS. TO FIX SECRETIVE
FASTRACK AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THREE REQUIRE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
IMPLEMENT HOUSING NEEDS NUMBERS.
FOR FUND AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND LASTLY DEFEAT PROPOSED
LEGISLATION THAT DISCOURAGES
RENTAL HOUSING CONSTRUCTION.
IN CONCLUSION WELL THIS
INITIATIVE WOULD REPEAL THE
COSTA HAWKINS RENTAL HOUSING ACT
IN ITS ENTIRETY.
IT WILL ONLY SERVE TO FURTHER
EXACERBATE THE HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS BY
DECREASING EXISTING RENTAL
HOUSING STOCK AND STIFLING NEW
INVESTMENT RENTAL HOUSING.
SEE OUR POSES THIS INITIATIVE
AND INSTEAD LOOKS FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THIS LEGISLATURE A
PROPOSALS THAT WILL BOLSTER THE
STATE'S HOUSING SUPPLY.
I THINK YOU AGAIN MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK BEFORE YOU
TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THE
FINAL WITNESS --
MISTER GUMBO.
THANK YOU NOT USUALLY ASKED TO
BAT CLEAN UP BUT I'LL DO MY BEST
SO -- MY
NAME IS FIRST OF ALL I THINK
ABOUT THE THE CHAIRS AND THE
COMMISSION.
COME A COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU
ARE SUCH A CRITICAL ISSUE.
MY NAME IS JOHN GAMBLE AND I
HAVE.
BEEN A COMMUNITY ADVOCATE AND
LEADER FOR OVER FIFTY YEARS ON
IT.
I HAVE BEEN --
THE CO FOUNDER AND THE DIRECTOR
OF TWO OF THE MAJOR OF MINORITY
A ADVOCATE ORGANIZATIONS THE
GREEN LINING INSTITUTE AND
LATINO ISSUES FORM.
I WAS A MENTOR IN THE TEACHER
FAR.
OF ORSON AGAIN ARE WHO IS A NEW
CHIEF OF DIRECTOR OF GREEN
LINING INSTITUTE BUT I DIDN'T
TEACH HIM EVERYTHING YET HOT.
I'M REPRESENTING TODAY HAVE THE
TWO HUNDRED THE TWO HUNDRED IS A
RELATIVELY NEW ORGANIZATION ON
IT WAS --
FOUNDED BY.
THAT SOME OF THE MOST REVERED
AND SUCCESSFUL CIVIL RIGHTS
LEADERS IN THE STATE.
INCLUDING GEORGE BEING HE WAS
PRESIDENT OF THE URBAN LEAGUE'S.
CRUZ REYNOSO FORMER SUPREME
COURT JUSTICE HERMAN GUY A CALLS
A FOUNDER OF THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL OF LA RAZA.
TYPE IN NAME FROM THE A KOREAN
COMMUNITY AND OTHERS HAN IT.
ALL OF US [inaudible]
OUR VOLUNTEERS AND CONTRARY TO
SOME OF THE ACCUSATIONS THAT
I'VE HEARD.
WE DO NOT.
A UX GET ANY PAY.
ANNE AND ORGANIZATION ON WE CAME
TOGETHER FOR ONE PURPOSE AND
HOPEFULLY WILL BE ABLE TO WORK
OURSELVES OUT OF A JOB.
THE ONE PURPOSE IS TO ADDRESS.
FIRST OF ALL OF US WERE RETIRED.
WE CAME TOGETHER BECAUSE OF THE
GROWING WEALTH GAP AFFECTING THE
MINORITY COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA.
THE INSIDIOUS AND GROWING WEALTH
GAP.
AND WE FEEL THAT THE METHOD.
OF ADDRESSING THIS WEALTH GAP.
IS WILL DO IS TO USE THE SAME
AVENUES THAT CREATED THE GREAT
WHITE MIDDLE CLASS SCIENCE
COUNTRY AND THAT IS
HOMEOWNERSHIP.
IN OUR EXPERIENCE.
ALLTHESE YEARS WE HAVE SEEN
GOOD AND BAD INITIATIVES.
INITIATIVES THAT SOMETIMES HELP
OUR COMMUNITY AND SOMETIMES
HEARD OUR COMMUNITY.
THIS IS NOT ONE OF THE ONES THAT
HELP.
WE KNOW THAT TO HAVE IT IS
PROMOTED BY SOME OF THE BEST
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY WHO HAVE
BEEN DOING GOD'S WORK.
BUT IT'S UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
OUR REVERSE OF WHAT ITS INTENT
TO HIS IT WILL INCREASE THE
HOUSING CRISIS INSTEAD OF DEEP
DECREASING MET.
THE MINORITY COMMUNITY IS
ALREADY.
SO FAR BEHIND IN WEALTH IN IN
HOMEOWNERSHIP BECAUSE OF THE
PAST DISCRIMINATIONS
[inaudible]
OF REDLINING [inaudible]
PREDATORY LENDING.
AND THE FAILURE OF REGULATORY
AGENCIES TO COULD TO REGULATE
THE FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS ON IT.
NOT ONLY WERE WE STARTING TO
CLOSE THAT WEALTH GAP.
FROM A NINETEEN SEVENTY ON TO
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT BECAUSE
OF THE ACTIVITIES OF GREAT CIVIL
RIGHTS ERA.
OUR LEADERS ON IT.
BUT ALONG COMES A GREAT
RECESSION.
AND THIS FROM GREAT RECESSION.
PUT OUR COMMUNITY BACK. THIRTY
YEARS IN WEALTH IN THREE YEARS
WE LOST THE WEALTH GAINED IN
THREE YEARS [inaudible]
TODAY.
THE MINORITY COMMUNITY
HOMEOWNERSHIP IN CALIFORNIA IS
ABOUT 50% OF WHITE.
IT'S MOST ASTOUNDING THOUGH IS A
WELL.
QUITE WEALTHY SIXTEEN TIMES
GREATER THAN MINORITY WELL FUNDS.
AND LOT OF THIS IS ATTRIBUTED TO
THE HIGH COST OF HOUSING IN IN.
IN THE STATE.
THIS INITIATIVE IS WELL INTENDED
BUT WHAT IT WILL DO.
IS A WORLDLY.
CREATE THE FEAR.
OF INVESTORS AND LANDLORDS AND
THIS FEAR WILL INHIBIT THEM FROM
MAINTAINING THEIR PROPERTIES AND
CREATING NEW PROPERTIES TO ADD
TO THE SUPPLY.
YOU'VE HEARD OF ALL THE SPEAKERS
TALK TODAY THAT THE MAIN PROBLEM
THE HOUSING CRISIS THERE'S A
LACK OF SUPPLY THE LACK OF
SUPPLY KEEPS.
YEAH I THE HOUSE THE HIGH COST
OF HOUSING THAT THE HIGH COST OF
HOUSING IMPACTS
DISPROPORTIONATELY.
MINORITY THE MINORITY COMMUNITY
ON IT.
WHAT WE NEED A TIME --
PROPONENT OF SOME KIND OF RENT
STABILIZATION.
BUT THIS PARTICULAR INITIATIVE
DOES NOT PROMOTE THAT.
IT CREATES A DEMOCRATIZATION IF
YOU WILL OF DIFFERENT RANT STE
ACROSS THE STATE THAT WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND LOCAL COMMISSIONS.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND LOCAL
COMMISSIONS HAVE NOT BEEN GOOD
TO THE MINORITY COMMUNITY.
THEY HAVE NOT IMPLEMENTED THE
HOUSING ELEMENT LAWS THEY WERE
SUPPOSED TO AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE
SO FAR BEHIND IN IN HOUSING.
WHAT WILL HAPPEN WITH THIS
INITIATIVE GIVING MORE POWER TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND --
COMMISSIONS.
IT WILL ALLOW THEM. TWO BECAUSE
OF FEAR OF THE WEALTHY A
RESIDENTS.
ALLOW HIM TO USE RENT CONTROL AS
ANOTHER FORM OF NAME BE IT'S ON
WE DON'T NEED THAT TON.
NOT ONLY THAT IT WILL CONTRIBUTE
TO THE GENTRIFICATION WHICH
WE'RE TRYING TO STOP --
DOT NET ON NOT GOOD USES.
WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE?
IN THIS STATE RIGHT NOW.
IS WERE EATING OUR SEED CORN.
WE ARE FAILING TO INVEST IN THE
FUTURE OF THE PEOPLE THAT WE ARE
GOING TO NEED.
TODAY [inaudible]
MULLIN MEALS MINORITIES AND
STUDENTS WILL BE COUNTED UPON.
PAY.
NOT OWN TO TO PAY THEIR HERE
EXORBITANT STUDENT DEBT THAT
THEY HAVE.
THEY'LL BE ASKED TO THE BE
TRYING TO FEED THEIR S. SUPPORT
NEW FAMILIES.
KEEP A ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD.
AND WE ARE ASKING THEM. TO TAKE
ON THE BURDEN OF SUPPORT.
OF THE OF OUR ELDERLY OR THAT
THE ENTITLEMENTS WE HAVE BECOME
ACCUSTOMED.
TO THEY'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
DO THIS IT'S GOING TO CREATE.
IT'S GOING TO CREATE A RACIAL
SLUR --
TENSION MORE THAN WE ALREADY
HAVE BANKS DUE TO MR TRUMP EDNA
AND OTHERS ON IT.
IT WILL ALSOCREATE A TENSION
BETWEEN.
YOUNG FAMILIES AND OLDER
FAMILIES YOUNG FAMILIES FIELDING
THE BURDEN OF HAVING TO TO
SUPPORT THE OLD OLDER FAMILIES
WHO DID NOT INVEST IN THEM SO
THEY COULD.
HAVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON WE
NEED TO ADDRESS THE THE ISSUE OF
OF RENT CONTROL IN A WAY ON A
STATEWIDE BASIS SO THE LOCAL --
TOLD THIS NOW THAT THE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THIS IS NOT THE ANSWER.
WE NEED TO GET TOGETHER ALL THE
SITE OF PEOPLE EVERYBODY.
GET TOGETHER AND COME UP WITH AN
ANSWER THAT'S A LONG RANGE THIS
IS TOO SHORT RANGE THAT HELPS
TOO FEW PEOPLE. FOR SUCH A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME WE NEED A LONGER
PLAN.
THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE ASKED CENTER ANY QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
CENTER.
I'M JUST RESERVE IF ONE OF YOU
CAN TELL ME WHAT WHAT IS A FAIR
RATE OF RETURN.
BY WAY OF THIS INITIATIVE IT'S
NOT DEFINED --
SO WE HAD A LOT OF LAWSUITS
PRIOR TO COSTA HAWKINS BECAUSE
IT WAS DEFINED SO LANDLORDS
WOULD GO TO THEIR RENT BOARDS
AND ASK FOR AN INCREASE IN RED --
MAYBE BECAUSE THEY HAD TO PUT ON
A NEW ROOF FOR MAYBE THERE WERE
LOCAL REQUIREMENTS --
THERE WERE ALSO LAWSUITS WHEN
THEY DIDN'T GET.
A I AUTHORIZED INCREASE --
HERE WE AGAIN DON'T HAVE A
DEFINITION OF FAIR RATE OF
RETURN SO WE BELIEVE NOW BECAUSE
OWNERS.
CAN'T RECEIVE A RENT INCREASE
POTENTIALLY UPON VACANCY.
IF THEY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IMPOSE
VACANCY CONTROL WE'RE GONNA SEE
MORE REQUESTS --
FOR A QUOTE FAIR RATE OF RETURN
AGAIN UNDEFINED.
AND IF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
DECIDES TO SETTLE AND AUTHORIZE.
A RATE INCREASE.
PROPONENTS CAN NOW CHALLENGE
THAT RENT INCREASE AND THE STATE
WILL BE A FORCED TO PAY FOR
THOSE TYPES OF LITIGATION THAT
WE WILL SEE COMING FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NO SIR
ANDERSON WELCOME ALRIGHT JUST TO
FOLLOW UP.
WHEN YOU SAY THEY'LL BE FORCED
TO PAY THE LEGAL FEES?
DO YOU MEAN OF THE DEFENDANTS OR
DO YOU MEAN.
OF THE PEOPLE CORD CHAIRMAN
JAMES.
WHY WOULD THEY BE ALL THE LEGAL
FEES ARE JUST VERY LEGAL FEES?
THE INITIATIVE IS VERY CLEAR --
THAT IF --
PROPONENTS FOR EXAM ARE AND
HAPPY WITH A LOCAL DECISION.
THEY CAN CHALLENGE THE
INITIATIVE OR THEY CAN CHALLENGE
I SHOULD SAY THE LOCAL.
ACTION.
AND THIS INITIATIVE REQUIRES.
THAT THEIR ATTORNEYS FEES BE
PAID WHETHER THEY WIN OR LOSE.
OUT OF THE APPROPRIATIONS THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
SO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WILL
PAY.
THOSE LEGAL FEES ACCORDING TO
THIS INITIATIVE.
SO IF I WAS AMBITIOUS ATTORNEY.
AND I COULD FIND MULTIPLE
LAWSUITS I WIN WITH OUR WHEN I
LOSE SECRETARY ABSOLUTELY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RIGHT AT THE CENTER ONE OF THANK
ARE THE PANEL FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS AND EXCUSE YOU AT
THIS TIME WE WILL NOW PROCEED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT.
AS I STATED THE OUTSET OUR WE
HAVE TWO MICROPHONES ON THE
GROUND FLOOR I THINK WE HAVE ONE
MICROPHONE ON THE TOP FLOOR.
WE WILL BEGIN ON THE GROUND
FLOOR AND WHAT I'M GOING TO DO
IS I'M GONNA ALTERNATE BETWEEN
THE MICROPHONE AND LEFT THE
MICROPHONE OF THE RIGHTS OF
FOLKS COULD PLEASE LINE UP.
IF FOLKS COULD PLEASE LINE UP.
IF YOU WISH TO EXPRESS YOUR
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION.
WE ARE GOING.
TO DO PUBLIC COMMENT FIRST ON
THE GROUND FLOOR AND THEN WE'RE
GOING TO GO UP TO THE BALCONY.
ARE IF I COULD ASK AGAIN FOLKS
TO PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OUTSIDE IF YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE A CONVERSATION.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OUTSIDE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
UNTIL YOU DO I'M NOT GONNA START
THIS AND THIS IS GOOD THIS COULD
TAKE QUITE SOMETIME SO I ASK YOU.
TO PLEASE [inaudible]
OKAY.
ABOUT IT IT DOES NOT NEED TO
LINE UP WE'RE JUST ASKING FOLKS
TO LINE UP ON THE GROUND FLOOR.
AND JUST TO BE CLEAR AGAIN WHAT
WE ARE ASKING EVERYONE TO DO --
IT IS TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE --
IT IS ABLE TO PROVIDE THE SAME
TESTIMONY YOUR NAME [inaudible]
YOUR AFFILIATION.
IF YOU WANT TO PROVIDE PLACE
RESIDENTS AND THEN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE.
ONLY SO FOR EXAMPLE JOHN SMITH
REPRESENTING TEN ORGANIZATION OR
PARTNER ORGANIZATION ACTS LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA.
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE.
HOPEFULLY THAT IS CLEAR AND
WITHOUT WHAT WE HEAR FROM OUR
FIRST MEMBER THE PUBLIC FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT.
JUST IDENTIFY YOURSELF PLEASE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YOUR TESTIMONY IS
DONE.
AS WE SAID YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION A PLACE RESIDENTS
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE [inaudible]
THANK YOU. TO RETURN THE
MICROPHONE PLEASE.
OKAY.
DOT THAT'S NONE GULGONG THEY
THEY GO MAGNATE HYPING THOSE
THINGS THE LATE LATE ARGUED ON
THE TICKET WILL PICK IT THE
YOUNG TOM MY LATE.
A YES THING HIGH NARAL WILL
REPEL COSTA HAWKINS.
OKAY LET ME AND MAKE THAT.
THANK YOU GUYS ARE MANG.
MAINTENANCE HAYAMI MULTILATERAL
SURE LIE ALONG THOSE SAW YES
PRICE NO REPEL COSTA HAWKINS WAS
A YES OR NO RENT CONTROL OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET'S GO TO
THIS MICROPHONE SIR.
MY NAME IS FERNANDO NO DAHLE I'M
WITH THE A SOAK IN A STATION
HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
AND NOTHING REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
STOPPED THE BRILLIANT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND APPOINT YOU VERY MUCH SIR.
BACK TO THIS MICROPHONE WE'RE
GONNA ALTERNATE MICROPHONES.
MA'AM MY NAME JENNIFER HSIA I'M
REPRESENTING THE HOMEOWNERS IN
OUTGROWN Y. M. STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE OF THE INITIATIVE I WANT
LIKE THE A LAWMAKER TO SAVE THE
BECAUSE DOLE HOPKINS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SHAPE THAT MAKE IT
VERY MUCH.
MY NAME IS A WITH THE NEEDS NOT
ALL I'M STATE REP PERCEPTIBLE.
ACE ALLIES COPPERY COMMUNITY
PROGRESS A REPEAL COSTA HOPPING
RICH TOO DAMN HIGH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH [inaudible]
NEXT SPEAKER [inaudible]
MA'AM [inaudible]
YEAH.
SIXTEEN CAN I DO THE CHARLIE
SAID YES YES REPEAT [inaudible]
HER NAME [inaudible]
I AND SEES A SMALL PROPERTY
OWNER SHE ONE IS SAFE COSTA
HAWKINS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
NEXT BIGGER MY NAME IS MARILYN
KIM AND I AM WITH EIGHTIES
RICHMOND CALIFORNIA AND WE SAY
EPEAL GOTTLOB GAME AS THAT THE
GENOCIDE.
NEXT SPEAKER MIGHT AND AGAIN I
ASK PEOPLE TO PLEASE TO POLICE
ASSIST YOU CALL --
SEE THE HOLDS HER.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW HOW CAN
[inaudible]
HOW CAN?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WEEK A PLACE STANLEY CHAN
FROM SAN FRANCISCO I'M A RETIREE
AND I WANT TO STAND ON COSTA
HAWKINS THANK YOU.
NEXT BIGGER.
MY NAME IS THE YOU ARE HERE.
SOLVENCY.
AND SAFE SAVE A LIFE BECAUSE I
THINK YOU.
IT IS TOUGH YES YOU WANNA SAVE
BECAUSE I HAPPEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH HOUSE MIGHT TURN.
BOB ON THE OTHER MICROPHONE
PLEASE.
AND FAMILY LEAVE AND FROM SAN
FRANCISCO I'M A HOST OWNER.
I WANT TO A SAFE BECAUSE STOCK
BARGAINS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT SPEAKER MY NAME IS BECKY ME
FROM SAN FRANCISCO I'M A SMALL
PROPERTY OWNER PLEASE SAFE
BECAUSE THE HAPPEN THANK YOU
[inaudible]
NEXT BIGGER.
MAN MAN THE CITY RIGHT NOW I
COME -- FOR
SON FOR US IS A CULT.
AMBER A PAIR AND CLUB OWNER.
AND LONG DOES [inaudible]
PEACE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WEEK MY NAY CHEN BEN AND
WHILE I'M SAID ONCE THAT YOU GO.
I SAY.
BECAUSE HE THAT HARD WORK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
ROXANNE ALBERT TOLLEY SAN
FRANCISCO RENTAL PROPERTY OWNER
SAVE COSTA HAWKINS THANK YOU.
NEXT BIGGER I AM IF YEAH RIVALS
ON SOME OF THE GOAL I AM.
BUT WHEN THEY SEE COST THAT
HAPPENED THANK YOU OKAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MY NAME IS MALIA SIGN.
MY NAME'S PAIN QUAN.
CONFIRMS SAN FRANCISCO
[inaudible]
OWNERS SAFE [inaudible]
COSTA HAWKINS.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS EMILY LOPEZ
FOR MY FAMILY FOR ALL FIVE
PEOPLE PRETTY SAFE --
BECAUSE THE HEART DISEASE.
HI MY NAME'S LORI QUAN FROM.
COME FROM SAN FRANCISCO I WANT
TO SAY.
COSTCO HOCKETT PRES.
MY NAME IS MAGGIE AND FORUMS
AMEND CISCO AND I AM SMALL
PROPERTY OWNER.
I WANT TO SAY.
FOR BECAUSE SAID HUMPTY.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S AYE SABLE AYE COME
FROM SOME CISSOKHO I WANNA SAFE
THOUGH BECAUSE AFRICAN.
THANK YOU NICK SPEAKER MY NAME
IS SANDY TAM FROM FREE MONTHS.
PLEASE SAVE WILL COSTA HAWKINS
PLEASE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS PAUL MY FIVE WILL IN
HIGH.
A ME COME FUNDS AND SEQUEL.
AYE VIEW HAT WILL KEEP THE
CATTLE [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
EXPERIMENT ME SKINNY SIERRA COME
FROM SOME OF THE CISCO.
I AM A SMALL PER PARTY HOMEOWNER
I WANT TO SAVE --
CUSTOM HOOKING PREACHED THANK
YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS A PRIVATELY.
I YOU KNOW I'M COME FROM SOME
CISCO I WANT TO STATE THAT I
WANT TO USE OUR YOU KNOW PLEASE
TO SAVE THOSE HOUSE OF CARDS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY THEM IS CHEN THEM --
COME BOB THOMAS'S CHO I
PREVENTION FEET DIDN'T HOLD US.
TO STAY STRONG GOOD TO SAY JUST
KEEP -- OUT
A WHAT.
YOU HAVE TO BECAUSE HAWKINS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MY MY THANKFUL.
SLAMS AT MRS [inaudible]
PEACE SAYS.
BECAUSE THE HOT PINK
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY DAMN LIFE HOMELESS ONLINE
SEUSSICAL AUSSIE MORAL
[inaudible]
I SEE COURTS HUNTING.
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER.
MY AND HE SAID NAME THOU LA
[inaudible]
SAUDI.
MY NAME IS KATHLEEN ALONE.
NUMBER FROM THE SAME PER HANDLE.
I WANTED TO SAY FOR THE COSTA
PICKUPS.
THANK THANK YOU NEXT MY NAME IS
SAMANTHA LA I FOR THEM A SEMI
SISSY CALLED.
AS TYPES IN MY PROPERTY A HOUSE.
ACT AS A SAVINGS GUY
[inaudible]
BUT MY NAME'S PETER WONG FROM
SEVEN CISCO WE NEED MORE HOW
SANE AND SAFE COSTA HAWKINS.
MY LIMIT YELPING CA A COME FROM
THE SAN FRANCISCO --
CLUB SMALL BECAUSE CITY.
AND THEN LEASE LORD HAVE BE --
FROM SAN FRANCISCO SAVE COSTS.
HAWKINS PIECE [inaudible]
NEXT WEAKER.
YEAH MY DAYS SAID CHUNG PULLIN
I'VE COME FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
I'VE RELY TO SAVE COSTS THAT
HOCKEY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS HE LONG ROLE I'M FROM
SOME PHYSICAL.
PREVIOUSLY SAVED COSTA HAWKINS
[inaudible]
THANK.
MY NAME IS WILLIAM CHOI NOW I'M
A SMALL LANDLORD FROM OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA SAVE MY NEIGHBORS
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
[inaudible]
NNOVA.
NEXT BIGGER PLEASE MY NAME IS
SUING ME I COME --
FOR SOMEONE SAYS POLL I NEED
TOLL SAFE.
BECAUSE CLARA HOGGAN.
MY NAME IS CAITLYN MILLER I AM A
LANDLORD AND HOMEOWNER IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA SAVE MY
TENANTS REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
[inaudible]
NEXT BIGGER.
MY NEPHEW SPANIEL AND FLOODING
SENATE SISKEL I WANT SAFE.
WELCOME [inaudible]
NEXT BAKER [inaudible]
BRUCE ROBERTS.
SABRE HARD ACTION COULD BELIEVE
SAN JOSE ALONE SAN JOSE.
AM --
SECTION EIGHT RECIPIENT.
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
[inaudible]
NEXT WEEK.
PETER I SAID EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF SMALL PROPERTY OWNERS IS HAD
PRINCESS GO.
SAVE COSTA HAWKINS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
NEXT WEEK [inaudible]
SAVE.
COSTA HAWKINS MY NAME IS OF YOU
IN PAN --
I'M NOT I'M DISABLED --
FIRM FREMONT HIGH REPRESENTS THE
SPACE MORE DEVELOPERS AND I'M
NOT AND I MEET OUR CITIES
HOUSING PROVIDERS.
PEACE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SAVE OUR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
NEXT BIGGER.
HELLO MY NAME IS NONI RICH AND
I'M A SMALL PROPERTY OWNER IN
SAN FRANCISCO I'M PRESIDENT OF
THE SMALL PROPERTY OWNERS OF SAN
FRANCISCO WE ASK YOU TO PRESERVE
COSTA HAWKINS THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT BECAUSE I'M JEALOUS
BELLSON.
I'M A SENIOR THAT REPRESENTS
THOUSANDS OF TENANTS IN LOS
ANGELES AND OUR ONLY HOPE TO NOT
PUT EVERYONE ON THE STREET.
IS TO REPEAL COSTA HOPE HAWKINS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT BIGGER.
MY NAME IS ALEX SCHOOL OF
MEMBERS OF THE SOMEONE CISCO
SMALL PROPERTY OWNERS
ASSOCIATION.
I'VE HOUSEHOLD OF TEN PEOPLE KIT
COSTA HAWKINS LAW THANK YOU.
MY NAM YOU'VE BEEN LONG SOME
ASSOCIATE THAT SIGNAL COAST.
HI MY NAME IS A VERY LOW --
COME FROM THE MEDICAL I WANT TO
SAY --
BECAUSE THE HOGAN THANK YOU NEXT
WEEK.
MY NAME IS A TO RESOLVE LONG I'M
REPRESENT THINKS HOME OWNERSHIP.
SAFE BECAUSE THE HAWKING THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WEEK.
MY OTHER HOBBY LA I COME FROM
SOME AS A SICKO.
BIASED SAFE COSTA HAWKINS.
THANK YOU NEXT BICKER.
HELLO MY NAME IS CELINE TO PLAY.
I DON'T WANT HOMELESS I I DON'T
WANT RENT CONTROL.
THANK YOU NAY SPEAKER.
NOW.
EXCUSE ME IF I COULD PLEASE ASK
EVERYONE TO RESPECT ALL OF THE
SPEAKERS WERE HERE.
THANK YOU MA'AM A RESUME AND
SENDS IT ONLY.
STATE I HOPKINS AND PLEASE.
HI MY NAME IS THAT [inaudible]
PETER.
AND HAVE BEEN A BIG FAN RAY
ABOUT FIFTEEN I LIE --
TO YOU WILL.
DIRECT CONTROL AND ALSO SAYS
SAFE.
THERE COSTA HOPPING THANK YOU
[inaudible]
I SPEAKER.
MY NAME IS WENDY LONG AM REAP
ASCENDING BAY AREA HOME OWNER
NETWORK WE HAVE.
OVER ELEVEN HUNDRED PEOPLE
MEMBERS WHO ARE WORKING NINE TO
FIVE JOBS.
PEACE IS SAFE.
COSTA HAWKINS THANK YOU.
NEXT BIG MY NAME'S JEALOUS OF
ALL [inaudible]
I AM.
LIBYA SAN IS SOUTH SENDS IT GO
NOT A MY FRIEND NAME PEOPLE BILL.
SO I ONE IS SAFE THERE BECAUSE
THE LAW CAN.
YEAH THINK GILMER THANK YOU.
ROB BANKS BECAUSE OH HI MY NAME
IS JESSICA SHOOTING.
UP IN MY PERMEABLE HAVE FIFTY
MEMBERS SO I WOULD LIKE TO
PRESENT.
THEM TO A SAFE HOSKIN POCKETS.
THANK YOU NICK SPEAKER MORE TO
RETURN TO RETURN TO YOUR HOME
ALL ALONE.
ON JOB HUNTING ON LARA CROFT
EUROPA.
QUESTION NEXT BECAUSE I MY NAME
IS CO YOU PUT ON SOME ASSIST
GOAL.
I WANT THOSE SAFE BECAUSE THE
HOKIES.
PLEASE AND THANK YOU.
HELLO MY LIMBS DAME I MY NAME IS
FERRELL IS ABOUT AN ACTIVIST
WITH THE SHE DOES MOVE A AND I
SAY REPEAL HOPE COSTA HAWKINS
THAT'S BECAUSE OUR HOME WITH ITS.
THINK YOU THINK YOU.
SPEAKER MY LIMBS SO YOU'RE A
INCOME THOSE HAVE AS ITS GOAL
I'M REPRESENT MY FAMILY AND MADE
THE BED THE HOT LOOKING PEOPLE
HOMEOWNER.
WE WANT A SAFE WITH THE COSTA
HAWKINS THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE
MAN IS WHO RUNS ON SAYING --
LOOMS SOMEONE PHYSICAL
[inaudible]
SAY.
THANK YOU MY NAME'S TO MAY I'M
FROM SAN FRANCISCO [inaudible]
SAVE COURSE.
HA HUGGING.
WORKING WELL.
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER JOB IT LONG.
SOMEONE SERVE SIX THE CALL.
AND IT'S FEELING.
SAFE CONFERENCE CUTLER HOW DID
HOW COULD SEE COCA.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS VANESSA BONUS I'M A TENANT IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO A
MEMBER OF AIDS.
AND I AM A TENET OF IMITATION
HOMES AND I WANT TO REPEAL COSTA
HAWKINS THANK YOU.
SPEAKER THERE AS WELL AS THEIR
OWN.
MY NAME IS IS ARE THERE LONG.
SEN VENDOR. ZERO ONE TO A SAFE
COSTA HAWKINS.
THE NEW WITH MARTIN ON THE SUN.
SIR DAVID BILLY MARTIN OPEN IN A
MEMBER OF A REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
THANK YOU NEXT PETER.
MY NAY EASES SAY YOU CLASS AND
WILL WANT TO LOOK.
AT FOR LONG THAT SAN FRANCISCO
SAVE COSTS HOT.
YOU THANK YOU XP HEY MY NAME
WITHOUT BY BEHIND HER BETTER
KNOWN AS BOND SAYING THEY LIVE
FROM SUMMER SAYS CALLED.
AYE AYE HOW.
GOODY YAKSHA ALL AYE PURPOSES
TOMORROWLAND.
AB BELIEVES HE SAID AT SHEA CARS
HERE HAWKING THINK YOU SAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS COOLEY REESE BROWN
BORN IN INNER CITY LOS ANGELES
SEVENTY THREE YEARS AGO.
AND HAVE SEEN VERY MUCH THANK
YOU MA'AM AND I'M ASKING YOU TO
PLEASE [inaudible]
SAY.
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT SPEAKER.
MY NAME IS IN THE WHILE I'M A
ESTIMATES SISKEL PUBLIC DEAL A
SMALL COMPANY OWNS THE P. SAY
COSTA HOSTAGE PINK YOU THINK
UNIX SPEAKER MY NAME IS THERESA
DO GAY I'M THAT I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR SOME FOR
THIS IS A COMMUNITY EMPOWERMENT
CENTER.
TODAY I WORK SEVEN DAYS A WEEK.
I HAVE THREE JOBS THANK YOU WHEN.
WE THINK COST THAT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
FRANCISCO.
I WHAT DO A JOB FOR MY DOWN
PAYMENT WANNA BUY A HOUSE.
I CAN'T DO IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET ME
ASK LET ME ASK IS THERE ANYONE
ON THE GROUND FLOOR WHO HAS NOT
HAD A CHANCE TO SPEAK IN PUBLIC
COMMENT.
IF NOT WE'RE GOING TO PROCEED TO
THE BALCONY ANOTHER FOLKS LINED
UP IF WE COULD JUST GET STARTED
WITH THE FIRST SPEAKER THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BEVERLY ROBERTSON I'M
FROM LOS ANGELES.
I'M THINK I'M GONNA ASK EVERYONE
TO PLEASE RESPECT THE SPEAKERS
FOR SPEAKING SO THAT EVERYONE
CAN GET A MOMENT.
TO EXPRESS THEIR PERSPECTIVE
PLEASE MA'AM THANK YOU.
I'M A LANDLORD AND I REPEAL
BECAUSE TALK OF THE RENT IS DUE
[inaudible]
TO THEY SPEAKER.
I LIKE THOSE RADICAL BELONG TO
ANY SECT MEDINA IS SET WHEN A
PARENT UNIT REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
RENTAL YOU NEXT WEEK.
HELLO MY NAME'S CRAIG COOK
RESIDENTS SACRAMENTO --
MEMBER OF DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS
OF AMERICA REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
NOW.
HOUSING IS A HUMAN RIGHT
[inaudible]
NAY SPEAKER.
MY NAME IS BRYCE MILLER WILLIAMS
I AM A MEMBER OF THE DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALISM.
MY NAME IS BRYCE LA THE WILLIAMS
A MEMBER OF THE DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALISTS OF AMERICA SACRAMENTO
CHAPTER A LONGTIME.
RESIDENT HERE INSTEAD IS SAN AND
I'M SICK OF SEEING MY FELLOW
CITIZENS KICKED OUT REPEAL COSTA
HAWKINS THANK YOU.
AGAIN I REMIND PEOPLE NAME
AFFILIATION WHERE YOU'RE FROM
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE.
I CASES IN AT DSA SACRAMENTO
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS THANK YOU
NEXT BIGGER.
CORY RING MY TEEN ES DE SA
SACRAMENTO REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
THANK YOU.
JAMES J. JACKSON JUNIOR
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS OF AMERICA
FOURTH GENERATION SACRAMENT IN
FIFTH GENERATION CALIFORNIAN
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS NOW
GODDAMMIT [inaudible]
THEY SPEAKER.
MY NAME IS CYRIL PAYS RAN OUT TO
OPEN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF WHERE
IT COULD.
BE A TO HOW I AM LIVING IN
SACRAMENTO NOW REPEALS COSTA.
THANK YOU.
JOHN PAUL DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS
OF AMERICA SACRAMENTO REPEAL
COSTA HAWKINS THANK YOU.
SAM GOING UP A MEMBER OF
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS OF AMERICA
SACRAMENTO A REPEAL COSTA
HAWKINS.
MY NAME IS ARIEL MY VETERAN AND
A MEMBER OF THE DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALISTS MOST AMERICA REPEAL
BECAUSE ON THINGS.
MY NAME'S DAVID TOURNAMENT
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS CALIFORNIA
REPEAL COST HASEN PROLETARIAT
OVER THE BOURGEOISIE ALL DAY
[inaudible]
NICK SPEAKER.
DAVID SHARPLES OF THE COMMUNITY
GROUP ACE IN RICHMOND CALIFORNIA
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS THANK YOU
NEXT BAKER.
MY NAME IS GEORGE STRING ON FROM
LOS ANGE CALIFORNIA I DIDN'T GET
AYE A GROAN AND A RIGHT HERE TO
REPEAL COSTA HOW.
THE NEXT SPEAKER AYE MORNING MY
NAME IS JUST OUR MONTH UP FROM
LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA M. WITH
ALLIANCES CALIFORNIANS FOR
COMMUNITY EMPOWERMENT REPEAL
COSTA HAWKINS.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
PATRICIA YOU ARE A COMING FROM
BAY PULLING CALIFORNIA IN A
REPEAL COSTA AWKINS NAY SPEAKER.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MIKE
THE CENTERS PROMISE ANGELES CD
AND A SMALL PROPERTY HONOR AM
PEACE TO BE REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS.
MY NAME IS PATRICK SMITH EMMITT
ACE MEMBER.
FROM MY LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA
I'M ALSO A PROPERTY OWNER AND
I'M HERE TO REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS.
MY NAME'S VELVA LOIS ON THE VICE
MAYOR OF THE CITY OF RICHMOND
AND AN ORGANIZER WITH AIDS THE
RENT IS TOO DAMN HIGH REPEAL
COSTA HAWKINS [inaudible]
MAKE SPEAKER.
MELISSA CROSBY RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA I'M IN ACE MEMBER AN
EDUCATOR AND THE CHAIR OF EAST
BAY MEDITATION CENTER.
AND REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS.
MY NAME IS SASHA GRAHAM I AM THE
CHAIR OF THE STATE BOARD OF ACE.
I WAS PUSHED OUT OF RICHMOND
ALLEN IN ALBANY REPEAL COSTA
HAWKINS SAVE OUR CHILDREN AND
OUR FAILURE IN PLEASE USE NEXT
BAKER.
MY NAME IS CATHERINE BOE METAL I
LIVE IN LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA
REPEAL COST.
HI MY NAME IS HER NAME ONLY I'M
FROM NORTHEAST LOS ANGELES I'M
AN ORGANIZER WITH ACE AND WITH
THE LA TENANTS UNION WE NEED TO
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS AND MAKE
HOUSING HUMAN RIGHT VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
NEW SPEAKER.
HEY MY NAME IS JACOB MOOCHER I'M
WITH THE DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS
OF AMERICA LOS ANGELES AND THE
LA TENANTS UNION.
U. S. ARE USELESS.
FOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
SPEAKER [inaudible]
MARILYN [inaudible]
MICROPHONE PLEASE.
AS MY* THANK YOU HELLO MY
NAME IS MARILYN I'M A MEMBER OF
THE PASADENA TENS UNION AND ALSO
A NEW LAWYER AND A HUGE AMOUNT
OF LAW SCHOOL THAT.
PLEASE REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
THANK YOU NICK SPEAKER.
HI I AM ALISON HENRY OF OF
PASSED THE ATTENDANCE UNION
PASSED IN A CALIFORNIA REPEAL
COSTA HAWKINS.
MY NAME IS GILBERT WILLIAMS
OSBORNE RACES HAVE FRANCISCO
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS.
MY NAME IS SARAH AND OUR I'M A
SMALL THEM GUARD IN OAKLAND AND
I'M A MEMBER OF PROPERTY OWNERS
FOR A FAIR AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
WE'RE CALLING ON YOU TO SAVE OUR
COMMUNITY IS VERY APPEALING
COSTA HAWKINS.
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER.
HELLO THANK YOU MY NAME IS HELEN
DUFFY I AM A STE A LANDLORD FOR
A FAIR AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
I COME FROM A A CITY THAT HAS
BEEN DEVASTATED BY DISPLACEMENT --
DUE TO HIGH RENTS THANK YOU.
NEXT BAKER HIGHWAY NAME SEVERAL
CHAU PROPUBLICA REPORTEDLY
HAPPENED IS REPAIRED COSTA
HAWKINS.
MY NAME IS CAROL FIVE DIRECTOR
OF OAKLAND SAN FRANCISCO AIDS
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS.
BUCHANAN FOR BREAKFAST LUNCH AND
DINNER WHIMS TOO DAMN HIGH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT BIGGER.
HEY MY NAMES OF THE DAM A
HUMANNESS AND I'M A RESIDENT OF
LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA PLEASE
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS WELL BUT ONE
SILENCE I'M FROM LOS ANGELES AND
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS THANK YOU.
NUMBER SEVEN REALLY WHAT WAS I
GONNA SPILL OVER AS OF RIGHT NOW
[inaudible]
DRAWS HIS.
OKAY IS THERE ANYONE OF THE
BALCONY OKAY CONTINUE PLEASE HI
MY NAME IS ARIEL SOLEIL I AM
FROM LOS ANGELES AND I'M AN
ORGANIZER WITH THE DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALISTS OF AMERICA AND WITH
THE HOUSING IS HUMAN RIGHTS
PROJECT.
AND PLEASE REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
GIVE POWER BACK TO THE WORKING
CLASS THANK YOU.
HI MY NAY ESSENTIALLY GO.
I BILL BECAUSE THE HOGAN
[inaudible]
NEXT BIGGER.
HI MY NAME IS ABLE GONZALEZ LIKE
DENVER LOS ANGELES AND PLEASE
REPEAT ACOSTA HOCKEY THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JEFFERSON THE D. I'M
WITH ACE AND PROPERTY OWNERS FOR
FAIR AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
A FROM SACRAMENTO A REAL ESTATE
BROKER REPEAL BECAUSE STOCKTON'S
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ANNE AND I'M ONE
OF THE STATE REPS FOR EIGHTIES I
LIVE IN OAKLAND.
AND IF YOU WANT TO DRESS TO
HOMEOWNERS HOMELESSNESS PROBLEM.
COSTA HAWKINS MUST BE REPEALED.
I CAN'T I CAN'T THANK YOU
[inaudible]
NEXT SPEAKER.
HOW MANY MS NICOLE DEAN I'M
ORGANIZER WITH ACE I'M FROM
OAKLAND AND I WANNA REPEAL COSTA
HAWKINS?
ALL THAT WE'RE NOT THAT IS ME
NOBODY IS SOLD AT A MIDDLE
BIGELOW THEY OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
ARTS THESE THOUGH IN THE BOTTOM
OF THE EIGHTH.
YES THOUGH YEAH I AM FAR WATER
THAT HE MAY NOT COSTA HAWKINS
DRESSES NEXT BIGGER.
MY NAME IS MARNIE HAMPTON FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY SCHOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS HOUSING IS
A HUMAN RIGHT THANK YOU.
NAMES JUST THEN THAT ORGANIZE IN
OAKLAND INTEND IT REPEAL COSTA
HAWKINS THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SUPER.
JOE.
AND I AM FROM SOME BY SECRET
SICKO SADIE CON.
MY NAME IS STILL TIME AND I AM
FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND SAFE
CALLISTO CLOSE WORKING.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S WIN IF OWN FROM SAN
FRANCISCO PLEASE SAVE.
CASA COSTA HAWKINS HAWKINS THANK
YOU.
MY UNDERSTANDING LONG LIKE THE
COME FROM ALAMEDA.
AYE SAFE CLOSE THE CALL COULD
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
TIME NOW FOR A LITTLE MORE SAY
THE MONEY TO A SAM RIPLEY FAR
MORE NO MORE MAY HAVE IS THERE.
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS NOW THANK
YOU [inaudible]
SPEAKER.
GOOD MORNING CECILIA CHACON
THERE ARE CULTURAL FULL OF SAN
FRANCISCO BASED GROUP REPEAL
COSTA HAWKINS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GET JIM SELLING ON OUR HOUSE
HAVE HOPE.
VOTER FORM A THREE MEMBER FOR
NON AMIGA.
SAY COSTA HAWKINS NO RENT AND
JILL THANK YOU [inaudible]
SPEAKER.
MY NAME IS EMILY I'M FROM
RICHMOND CALIFORNIA I OWN A
SINGLE FAMILY HOME PLEASE SAVE.
COSTA HAWKINS THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KATRINA HOLE I'M
REPEAT SAM BY CHINESE WILL STAY
ASSOCIATION.
P. SAFE COSTA HAWKINS THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DO YOU FIND THEM.
AND FUN SEVEN CITY LAW I DON'T
SIMONA PIECE SAFE AND KATE R.
COSTA HOW COME RELEASE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NICK SPEAKER.
HI MY NAME TO DAVID GONG FROM
MEANS CITY CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE SAFE COSTA HAWKINS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S NON NONSO FROM SAN
FRANCISCO PIECE TO SAVOR HAS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ROBERT LEE AYE RETIRE
I LIVE IN SACRAMENTO.
AND I LIKE TO SAY COSTS COULD
COSTA HAWKINS SO I DON'T HAVE TO
SELL MY PROPERTY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME STEVEN YEP I'M FROM SOME
CISCO ALSO HOUSE OWNER BISCUIT
BECAUSE HUCK [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANKS BAKER.
MY NAY SLING MAYBE I'M FINE
PERSON AND CALIFORNIA HAVE YOU
PERSON MY FAMILY TO SAVE THE ED
BECAUSE I HAWKINS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS A THAT'S HOW.
I AM FROM RICH MAN.
I'M THE PROPERTY MANAGER.
I AM HERE REPRESENTS EIGHTY FIVE
OFF THE PROPERTY OWNER FROM
RICHMOND. TO PLEASE KEEP COSTA
COTTON [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY DEAR YOU SEE YOUNG TO COME
FROM THE LEG IS TO MISS EACH
YEAR.
I SAY [inaudible]
FOR COSTA HAWKINS.
THANK YOU YOU.
MY NAME IS JEFF CAO LAW.
AND I FLOM SACRAMENTAL.
AND I AS SMALL.
A PEPPER MILL OWNER [inaudible]
PEACE [inaudible]
SAFE.
COSTA HOW COLD THANK YOU.
MAYBE THE POSI CHOMP I AM HERE
TO BE PERCENT HERE MY LUST
FRIENDS AND FAMILY MEANS A SWAP
PUBLIC ONUS. TO SAVE HERSELF
COSTA HAWKINS AND SAFE ALL SMALL
PROPERTIES NO RENT CONTROL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI I MY NAME SHERMAN KIM FROM
LAST SUMMER'S CISCO I'M
REPRESENTING SEVEN AND A SMALL
PROPERTY OWNERS --
WE NEED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PRIEST KIT COSTA HAWKINS THANK
YOU [inaudible]
MAP.
HELLO MY NAME IS PATRICIA
EVERETTE.
I'M A MEMBER OF A SACRAMENTO A
RETIRED EDUCATOR I WORK EVERYDAY.
TO AND I'M HERE TO SAY REPEAL
COSTA HAWKINS I CAN'T AFFORD TO
LIVE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS PEOPLE BEFORE
PROPERTY REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS.
MY NAME IS JON UP I HAD OF
THOUGH I AM FROM THE POINT
CALIFORNIAN I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
REPEALING COSTA HAWKINS.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE BALCONY.
OKAY AT THIS TIME WERE TO COME
BACK TO THE FIRST FLOOR.
PART OF THE CHAMBER LET'S HEAR
OF FROM THE RIGHT HAND SIDE
THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S
ALEXANDER HARD AND I'M A HOUSING
POLICY ADVOCATE WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE REPEAL OF
COSTA HAWKINS THINKING
[inaudible]
NICK SPEAKER.
MY NAME IS SAM TEPPERMAN
DELPHINE AND MY PROPERTY OWNER
IN SAN FRANCISCO REPEAL COSTA
HAWKINS THANK YOU [inaudible]
NAY SPEAKER.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MONO BETA AND I'M PART OF THE
GROUP AREA OF ACE AND SANTIAGO
AND I SUPPORT THE REPEAL OF
COSTA HAWKINS.
HI MY NAME ISCHRISTINA
LIVINGSTON I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF PEACE ABOVE RESIDENT
OF SACRAMENTO AFTER HAVING BEEN
DISPLACED FROM THE BAY AREA AND
I NEED.
TO IN DISPLAY THAT WE NEED TO
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT BICKER HI MY
NAME'S MIGUEL LOPEZ --
I'M WITH ACE IN SAN DIEGO AND I
SUPPORT THE REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS.
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER.
MY NAME IS LIZ RYAN MURRAY I'M
WITH CARSON WATCHING THE
ALLIANCE FOR HOUSING JUSTICE WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT REPEAL COSTA
HAWKINS THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARY MELENDEZ
SIMON ORGANIZER WITH ACE IN SAN
DIEGO AND THIS --
LAW HAS THIS PLEASE LET PEOPLE
INTO MEXICO SO THAT'S OUR
REALITY RIGHT NOW SO PLEASE
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS SO WE CAN
STAY IN OUR COUNTRY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT BAKER.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MIKE
VALLEY KINCAID AND I'M A
SACRAMENTO RESIDENT LONG.
IN ARDEN ARCADE AND I'M ALSO A
CANDIDATE FOR THE SON OF ONE
SCHOOL BOARD AND A LOT OF OUR
STUDENTS WOULD BENEFIT.
FROM REPEATING.
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON
DAVID WOLF AT THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION WERE IN
SUPPORT OF COSTA HAWKINS AND
HAVE TAKEN AN OFFICIAL OPPOSE
POSITION ON THE INITIATIVE THANK
YOU [inaudible]
MY SPEAKER.
MY NAME'S ELIANA BENDER I WAS
BORN AND RAISED IN BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA I'M A WRENCHING HERE
IN SACRAMENTO.
HOUSING IS A HUMAN RIGHT REPEAL
COSTA HAWKINS THANK YOU NEXT
BAKER.
HI I AM MITCHELL PARRIS ITEM
WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES --
I WAS BORN AND RAISED RIGHT HERE
IN SACRAMENTO AND I'M A LANDLORD --
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS.
HI MY NAME IS BILLION MODE AND
I'M A GRADUATE STUDENT AT UCLA
AND IT'S NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
FIND AFFORDABLE HOUSING RIGHT
NOW.
PLEASE REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS SHE ONLY FOR LEGAL I'M HERE
REPRESENTING POLICY LINK WE
SUPPORT THE REPEAL OF COSTA
HAWKINS AND HOPE YOU'LL SUPPORT
IT TOO THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON VICTORIA WONDER
WAS SIX MONTHS FOR SOCIAL EQUITY
AS PART THE REPEAL OF COSTA
HAWKINS.
THANK YOU NICK SPEAKER --
I'M WILLIAM FAIR FROM BRENTWOOD
A RENTER AND I SUPPORT THE
REPEAL OF COSTA HAWKINS.
I AM A THE IDEA SO WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES I'M A RENTER IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND REPEAL COSTA
HAWKINS HOUSING IS A HUMAN RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M RICHARD
MARCANTONIO MANAGING ATTORNEY AT
PUBLIC ADVOCATES.
COSTA HAWKINS WILL BE REPEALED
WHAT I'M LESS CERTAIN ABOUT IS
WHETHER THE HELL THANK YOU VERY
HARD ASSOCIATION WILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISREPRESENTATIONS
THANKYOU VERY MUCH SIR.
LET ME JUST REMIND EVERYONE NAME
AFFILIATION WHERE FROM AND THAT
SUPPORTER POSE NEXT WEEK.
HI MAY NAME'S BEEN WHAT IT WAS
SAY I AM A LAW STUDENT AND
RENTAL IN DAVIS CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT THE REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
THANK YOU.
NEXT WEEK.
WELL I'M MOB THOUGHT BEANS LIMIT
CANNOT GET THEM HE GOT UP WANT
TO BEND THE PLAN ALL PLACERVILLE
BLACK LIST LIVIN LA I WANT THAT
THE CLERK THE HAPPY YOU KNOW
MAKE IT ALL YOU THAT CALIFORNIA
BOOK IN THE LAWSUIT WILL ONLY
LOOK AT THAT.
MOMENT WHEN THE CALIFORNIA LOS
YET BUT CRISIS NEXT BIGGER HER
NAME IS MARIAM OF DEAN AND OF
SEIZE FOR MEXICO'S WHO LIVES IN
OAKLAND NOW.
AND OF SEIZE HERE TO REPEAL
COSTA HAWKINS HE DOESN'T WANT TO
GO TO MEXICO AS HE LOVES FOR
KIDS WHO LIVE HERE.
THANK YOU MAKE SPEAKER HELLO MY
NAME IS GOING UP BUT AT THIS AYE
WITH PUBLIC AT THE KIDS FORMER
BAY AREA RESIDENT --
RENTER NOW IN SACRAMENTO AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE REPEAL OF
COSTA.
THANK YOU MUCH BIGGER.
MY NAME'S WHOLESALE WITH ACE IN
SAN DIEGO --
I LIVE AT THE ONE IN MEXICO NOW
BECAUSE THE RENTS ARE TOO THAT
HIGH SO REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
THANK YOU NEXT WEEK.
TAYLOR JACKSON REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION WE
REPRESENT OVER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND UNION NURSES STATEWIDE
WE'VE ENDORSED THE BALLOT
INITIATIVE AND WE'RE HERE TODAY
AND STRONG SUPPORTER.
MAIN NUMBER OF BE SENT THEM OUT
OF BUSINESS THE YOU'LL BE ONE OF
SPECIALIST CALIFORNIA SO THEN
BEGIN ALSO DEALS THE ESTONIAN
THAT QUANTUM AVE BECAUSE THE
HOCKEY [inaudible]
GOOD.
FOR THEN THE MY THEME AND SEE --
SINCE TENANTS UNITED IN LOS
ANGELES MISTER SUPPORT THE
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS.
I CAN EXPECT.
ZECHARIAH KENDAMA STUDENT OF LAW
AND POLICY AT UC BERKELEY I LIVE
IN HAYWARD AND I'M HERE TO SPEAK
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF BILL COSTA
HAWKINS.
THANK YOU NICK SPEAKER.
MY NAME IS JUST YEAH MEAN THAT
ARE HIGHLY AVAILABLE ANGELES ARE.
AND DEALS WITH ME THOSE REPEAT
BECAUSE THE HOCKEY [inaudible]
SPEAKER.
BY ROBIN DENY MY OAKLAND
LANDLORD I AM A MEMBER OF THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION OWNERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
AND YET I SAY REPEAL.
THE HAWKINS THANK YOU.
NEW SPEAKER NEW KNOW MIDNIGHT
LEVEL MISS ITEM FROM LOS ANGELES.
RE-ATTEMPT.
THANK YOU NICK SPEAKER I'M
COLLETTE CRUTCHER I MISS AND THE
CISCO HONED HOMEOWNER AND I SAY
REPEAL COSTA [inaudible]
NICK SPEAKER.
HI MY NAME IS CRYSTAL.
I AM BORED I WAS BORN IN.
CALIFORNIA AND A I AM HERE TO
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS IRAN IS TOO
DAMN HIGH [inaudible]
TAKE CARE.
NEW SPEAKER ADAMANTLY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POST POSITIONS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ABIGAIL I'M FROM
CALIFORNIA I CAME FROM IT.
I'M A MEMBER OF EIGHTIES AND I'M
COMING OVER HERE TO REPEAT COSTA
HAWKINS.
MAKES PROGRESS YOU MIGHT AYE YOU.
I'M WHICH TOOK ON THE FLOOR NEAR
YOUR BABY GOT THIRTY FOUR NAMES
ARE INFORMED ABOUT.
THIS IF I WOULD ASSUME NOTHING
THOSE.
THANK YOU ALL ENOUGH OF THE
NUMBER OF MONEY ALSO DO EVEN ONE
AND SOME SIMPLE LITTLE HOW
HITLER.
IS TOILET BICU BUT BUT A
POLITICAL STUNT HOCKEY'S EVE BUT
ACTED BY ELEVENTH ABOUT THE LOS.
MANY US ODOT FROM SOUTH CENTRAL
LOS ANGELES.
MY NAME IS SELF EVIDENT THAT'S
BAD EYES CALIFORNIA MEMBER OF
MASON IN YOUR TO REPEAL THE
COSTA HAWKINS.
HI TO SEE HIM INJURE I'M FROM
RICHMOND CALIFORNIA AND I'M HERE
FOR REPEAL OF COLLEGE CASA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OIL AND THE NUMBER IS SELLING
AMONG US LINGO THEY LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA SO AND MEMBER OF THE
ICE LOVE IN THE SYSTEM WE ARE
THAT'S WHAT ABOUT WATER LEVEL
DATA COSTA HAWKINS GRASS YES
THIS IS A DEMO SO YOU LIKE
CALIFORNIA.
BUT IT WAS CERTAIN STILL ENOUGH
ROOM EIGHTIES LOS ANGELES AND
SHE'S HERE TO REPEAL COSTA
HAWKINS.
YES HELLO MY NAME IS STANLEY
CHAPMAN I'M FROM LOS ANGELES I'M
WITH AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION
I'M A COMMUNITY ACTIVIST AND I'M
HERE TO REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS I
STRONGLY SUPPORT REPEALING COSTA
HAWKINS.
I CAN EXPECT HER.
MY NAME IS JAMES DAIS OF
RICHMOND CALIFORNIA.
IF YOU'RE A GOD FEARING MAN YOU
WILL REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS I CAN
EXPECT A THE NUMBER S. CANDY.
FOR DE LOS OCULUS BENGAL BUT
RELUCTANT.
HAS PASSED [inaudible]
THANKS SPEAKER MY NAME IS ERIC
HARRIS SOME WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE NAACP AND WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE POSITION [inaudible]
THEY SPEAKER.
HI MY NAME IS NANCY SHARE I'M
FROM SANTA MONICA CALIFORNIA.
I'M HERE TO APPEAL COPS COSTA
HAWKINS --
RUBIO AND SOME FROM LOW FOUNDED
FROM HERE TO REPEAL COSTA
HAWKINS.
HELLO MY NAME IS HIGH MAKE
CATTERY LIVE IN CONCORD.
I'M AN ACE MEMBER AND I AM HERE
TO REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER MARVIN
GILLIAM WHITE I'M FROM --
THEM PETER CALIFORNIA'S WE FILL
COSTA HAWKINS THE RENT IS TOO
DAMN I EMILY SHARON.
FROM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND
I'M HERE TO SAY APPEAL COSTA
HAWKINS THE RENT IS TOO HIGH FOR
ALL OF US.
MY NAME IS FRANK GOLLY I'M A
SENIOR IN LOS ANGELES.
LIVING IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS OR I WILL
BECOME HOMELESS THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
NEXT SPEAKER [inaudible]
SIR.
HI MY NAME IS ARTHUR Y. DEVELOP
FROM LOS ANGELES AND I'M HERE --
TO SAY PLEASE --
RICK.
WHAT?
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS REPEAL
COSTA HAWKINS YOU SURE.
YES YOU ARE RIGHT YET SPEAKER
HELLO.
MY NAME IS CAMILLE SHORT LIE AND
I REPRESENT THE UC DAVIS UNITED
STUDENTS AGAINST SWEATSHOPS AND
I RESIDE IN A COLLEGE TOWN WITH
A 2% VACANCY RATE LITTLE SNOW
INCOME RIBBENTROP HOUSING.
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS THANK YOU.
A SPEAKER HI MY NAME IS NOT
REALLY ABOUT S. I AM IT'LL
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
SPEAKER.
YES MY NAME IS OF THE OF THE
MONTH NINA SOME A US CITIZEN AND
I'M HERE TO REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
ON NOVEMBER CHECKS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
HI THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MY
NAME IS DELIA MACGRATH I'M FROM
PACIFICA CALIFORNIA.
I WISH TO REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
SPEAKER TYRONE BUCKLEY ON BEHALF
HOUSING CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT
THE REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SUZANNE MORE FROM PACIFICA
pFOR FAIR AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
TO REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS THANK
YOU BRIAN AUGUST ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS.
THANK YOU HOW MY NAME IS
CHRISTINE MILLER I'M A MEMBER OF
ACES AND FROM OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
AND AND I LIKE YOU TO REPEAL
COSTA HAWKINS.
NUMBER THAT SET UP UP MISTER
CHAIRMAN HAULING MICHON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF WEST HOLLYWOOD
THE CITY OF AB WAS TOLLYWOOD
ENDORSES THE REPEAL OF COSTA
HAWKINS THANK YOU NEXT WEEK A
NUMBER OF ITS IMPACT ON THAT UP.
ON THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
PARTNER IN MANY.
HE HAS HIS [inaudible]
NEW SPEAKER.
I MADE NO MONROY --
SAGE STRATEGIC ACTIONS FOR JUST
ECONOMY FROM SOUTH CENTRALIA A
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS ENDEAVOR IN
BURDEN NOW THING CLICK UNIX
SPEAKER [inaudible]
NUMBER SO.
MINNESOTA AND IT'LL.
UP LITTLE SUNKEN IS THE PSYCHIC --
NO.
PHONES AND THANK.
MY NAME IS EDITH PASTRANA WITH
LINES OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
COMMUNITY EMPOWER MEN OUT OF THE
RICHMOND CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND
I'M HERE TO REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER.
I MEAN NUMBER HAD IT'S ALRIGHT
FOR ME THAT I AM OF THE LOS I
HAVE.
NEVER BEEN DONE THOSE I GET THEM
ALL COULD GET THEM EARLY PARKING
[inaudible]
THANK.
MY NAME IS LIZ KEEP LARA I'M A
MEMBER OF A STE APOLLO AND SCEI
YOU.
TEN TWENTY ONE RETAIL COSTA
HAWKINS THANK YOU.
NEXT BECOME A YES AND NO TO
SIERRA MOVING ON OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA.
FUND OUT SAY THE PAIN ALL OSAMA
BICU [inaudible]
CHRISSY SO REPEAL BECAUSE THE
HOT.
HOW MY NAME IS CHRISTIAN ALONG
NO FROM PACKED IN THE SILICON
VALLEY RENTERS RIGHT COALITION
IN SAN JOSE REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
Q.?
MY NAME IS JOSE CASTRO I'M
REPRESENTING SAGE I'M A FULL
TIME STUDENT FULL TIME EMPLOYEE
AND I AM AGAINST BECAUSE
STOCKINGS.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS STELLAR SOME OTHER TO
PASS THAT ON MOMENTO PACKED AND
THE SILICON VALLEY THERE'S RIGHT
COALITION [inaudible]
AND NO.
SUPPORT THE REPEAL OF COSTA
HAWKINS THANK YOU [inaudible]
SIR.
ON THE RIGHT HAND SIDE.
YELL MY NAME IS SANDI PERRY ON
THE PRESIDENT OF THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING NETWORK OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY --
AND WE SAY SAVE THE TENANTS
REPEAL REPEAL REPEAL THANK
[inaudible]
SPEAKER.
I MY NAME IS STEVE I COME FROM
LOS ANGELES CITY FROM
NEIGHBORHOOD CALLED SUN VALLEY.
HOW PART OF THE LOS ANGELES
TENNIS UNION AND THE COALITION
THAT'S GONNA PASS THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ACT?
AND REPEAL COST.
THANK YOU NEXT WEEK.
HELLO BUDDY LYDIA TRAIL UP A
BALLET I DON'T --
I WANT YOU REPEAT I'M ABBAS
REALLY REPEAL ALL I HAVE TO
HAWKINS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ROBERT A GARY FROM
SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA I REPRESENT.
THE BAY AREA DEMOCRATIC
LANDLORDS ALSO KNOWN AS BAD
LANDLORDS AND WE WANT TO REPEAL
COSTA HAWKINS THANKS MIX BAKER.
HI MY NAME IS BAO LET'S GO ITEM
OF FROM LOS ANGELES WITH LA CAN
THAT I AM HERE TO REPEAL BECAUSE
SOMETHING THINKS.
HELLO MY NAME IS AT AND THAT GOT
US SOME WITH THE LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY ACTION NETWORK IN
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES AND I'M
HERE TODAY TO REPEAL COSTA
HAWKINS THANKS NICK SPEAKER.
HI MY NAME IS NOT I'M.
NOT HERE TO REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
[inaudible]
NOW.
NOT FROM LOS ANGELES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT BIGGER MY NAME IS
STILL MY OVERDRAWN AND I'M FROM
CALIFORNIA LA AND REAP.
LIFE HEALTH [inaudible]
REPEAL HAAS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WEEK.
YOU'RE DO NOTHING AROUND NOT LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER REPEAL BECAUSE TALKING
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DANIEL I'M FROM LA
AND I WOULD --
AND I DON'T SUPPORT --
COSTA HAWKINS REPEAL IT
[inaudible]
SIR.
YES GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
STEVE VS AND I AM FROM LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA WITH AN
ORGANIZATION CALLED ALLEY CAT.
GOVERNMENT CANNOT BE ALL SHOW
AND NO SUBSTANCE REPEAL COSTA
HAWKINS BECAUSE THE RENT IS TOO
DAMN HIGH [inaudible]
Q..
LET'S GO BACK UP TO THE BALCONY
AGAIN SIR.
MY NAME IS JESSE BROKE SOME FROM
OAKLAND I'M A RENTER.
THE RAIN IS TOO DAMN HIGH I'M
ALSO AFFILIATED WITH AIDS HEALTH
FOUNDATION REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SPEAKER.
HI MY NAME IS ROGER ALLIES GOT
ON FROM OAKLAND.
AND MY DAD IS HOMELESS REPEAL
COSTA HAWKINS THANK YOU.
HIGH ON MR MONROE AND I AM HERE
TO REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS I AM A
RENTS THERE.
IN THE RAIN IS TOO DAMN HOT
[inaudible]
NEXT WEAKER.
HI HI MY NAME IS LAUREN STAMFORD
CEREMONY I'M HERE TO SAVE COSTA
HAWKINS.
HI MY NAME IS IVAN THE FARMS ARE
AMONG.
PIECE SAFE COSTA HAWKINS.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ROBERT HALL NUMBER IS
IN THE YOUTH PROGRAM APPEAL
COSTA HAWKINS THE RENT IS TOO
DAMN HIGH THANKS EIGHT Q..
NEXT SPEAKER [inaudible]
JOHN.
HI I'M RICH ALISON A REPAIR
COSTA HAWKINS [inaudible]
THANKS.
HI MY NAME IS JULIE MAXIMUM FROM
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA REPEAL CASA
HAWKINS.
MICHAEL SMITH OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA'S NEED RELIEF NOW
APPEAL REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THAT WISH TO SPEAK IN
PUBLIC COMMENT.
ANY OTHER OF THE PUBLIC WISH TO
SPEAK IN PUBLIC COMMENT
[inaudible]
GOING ONCE [inaudible]
GOING TWICE.
OKAY AT THIS TIME PUBLIC COMMENT
[inaudible]
LOW'S.
I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
YOUR PARTICIPATION IN THIS
HEARING AND WANT TO THANK ALL
THE WITNESSES AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT CAME FROM NEAR AND
FAR TO TESTIFY.
ALSO APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK OF
OUR SERGEANTS TODAY IN THE
LOGISTICS OF HELPING WITH PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION ARE AND WITH THAT.
THIS COMMITTEE MEETING IS NOW AT